Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Wo sind wir?
Wir sind in der Garderobe, der Cays, gehen gleich auf die Bühne. Wir wollen aber erst mal ankündigen, was wir als nächstes lesen. Was wäre? Wir bleiben Autoren treu. Wir haben schon mal ein Buch über Europa von Peter Sloterdijk gelesen. Jetzt hat er ein Buch geschrieben über die großen Männer. Und zwar hat das den Titel Der Fürst und seine Erben über große Männer im Zeitalter der gewöhnlichen Leute. Und auf dem Cover kann man schon sehen, dass da ein Donald Trump ist, aber zugleich in einem Historischen Gewand. Wir werden auf das Cover dann auch noch zu sprechen kommen. Es geht da so um die großen Männer in der Politik und was sie gerade bewirken oder verwirken. Wir werden aber noch ein zweites Buch lesen, nämlich Adrian Daub. Von ihm haben wir ja das Buch gelesen, was das Valley Denken nennt. Und jetzt hat er ein neues Buch geschrieben, was das Valley Herrschen nennt.
Theorien Paxis.
Ja, also wir sind sehr gespannt. Und das ist ja genau der richtige Ansatz jetzt, weil als das erste Buch rauskam, herrschten sie noch nicht in dem Sinne, dass sie im Oval Office laufen zu Gast waren und so eine Nähe hatten plötzlich zur Präsidentschaft, weil das damals noch die Biden-Administration war. Sie haben natürlich auch schon wirkmächtig gehandelt.
Genau.
Aber jetzt herrschen sie in einer ganz anderen Weise nochmal. Also ich bin sehr gespannt, denn wir fanden damals sehr gut das Buch.
Das Buch war sehr gut. Danach hat er sich der Cancel Culture gewidmet. Da haben wir gar nicht so drauf geschaut.
Nee.
Und jetzt sind wir wieder zurück bei Adrian Daub.
Ja, das steht also bevor. Im aktuellen Salon, da aufweisen wir auch nochmal hin, kann man jetzt gerade zwei Besprechungen hören. Wir haben einmal das neue Buch Geld als Waffe von Ulrike Herrmann gelesen. Wir sind, so sagen wir, nicht begeistert. Wir haben sehr viel zu kritisieren, sehr, sehr viel. Und auch nicht begeistert, aber doch sehr aufschlussreich, war die Lektüre von Bibis Buch. Bianca Heinicke hat sich eine neue Personality zugelegt. Wir stellen fest, nee, das ist eigentlich noch die Alte, nur im neuen Gewand.
Vielleicht hätten wir im Titel schreiben sollen, dass es Baby Beauty Palace und nicht Baby Netanyahu ist. Leute, die das gefunden haben, sind mir aber auch etwas danach aufgeschrieben.
Ja, ja, ja.
Bibis Buch habe ich reingeschrieben.
Da haben wir so unpolitisch gedacht, aber ja, natürlich.
So, was machen wir heute? Wir gehen gleich auf die Bühne und verabschieden den großen Denker Jürgen Habermas. Er ist tot. Ja, das ist schon, also klar, er ist sehr alt geworden. Er hat viel geschaffen, aber er hat auch Jünger, sozusagen, wie jeder große Theoretiker. Und die versuchen auch nochmal, ihn zu verabschieden. Und über die macht man uns lustig. Nicht direkt über Habermas, sondern über die.
Aber ich kann trotzdem vielleicht auch ein paar würdigend kritische Worte zu Habermas, gleichermaßen sagen, ja?
Ja, total, ja.
Gut. Dann haben wir einen ganz großen Blog, weil ich doch dachte, ja, wir machen jetzt zwar häufig sehr Unterhaltsames, aber es ist doch jetzt wichtig, weil so viel passiert, über den Krieg im Iran zu sprechen. Deshalb, weil ich mal Diskurse nachzeichnen will. Also wir gehen einmal wirklich in den amerikanischen Abgrund, gehen also wirklich zu den Neonazis und wie die jetzt gerade diesen Krieg von Trump bewerten. Dann machen wir wiederum eine große Reise nach Deutschland zurück und schauen uns da die Diskurse an. Und zwar möchte ich kontrastieren Joachim Gauck und Tino Chrupalla. Oh, gibt es noch einen Kontrast? Es gibt einen sehr deutlichen Kontrast. Und das Heikle ist ja wirklich, dass Tino Chrupalla heute Abend zugestimmt werden muss in mehrfacher Hinsicht und dann natürlich auch wieder nicht. Aber das ist eben das Fatale, was ich gerade sehe. Also ich will es mal so sagen, ich habe die Befürchtung, dass die AfD, wenn sich dieser Krieg zuspitzt und die Folgen zuspitzen, dass die AfD einen neuen Anlauf nehmen kann, der sie wirklich zu einer Volkspartei macht. Also es ist eigentlich sehr dramatisch und das liegt aber genau auch an dem, was wir dann werden an dem anderen Diskurs von Joachim Gauck vertreten. Und dann fragen wir uns zum Schluss nochmal, ja, was können wir jetzt von den Versprechen halten, die März gegeben hat? Sind da keine Versprechen oder Ankündigungen? Er wird da nicht mitmischen. Wir hören da ganz kurz rein, wie Markus Lanz das verhandelt. Und es ist wirklich sehr dramatisch. Aber ich fand es jetzt gut, darüber jetzt zu sprechen, weil in zwei Wochen oder zehn Tagen wir doch noch so viele andere Themen dazu beackern haben.
Okay. Und dann zum Abschluss muss Wolfgang heute ganz stark sein. Denn wir gucken uns die neuen Bilder an, die die KI produziert. Und ich finde das wahnsinnig unterhaltsam. Ja.
Und du willst mir heute Abend sagen, dass ich jetzt schon Hollywood Adieu sagen kann? Naja, noch sehr.
Du nicht. Das Kino, das dich interessiert wird, ist ja ohne schon seit Jahrzehnten Nische oder so bleiben.
Na komm.
Aber die großen Filme, die du natürlich auch würdest, allein weil sie große Filme sind. Und die aber auch jetzt nicht unbedingt oben listen bei dir. Die kriegen natürlich neue Konkurrenz. Und die Frage ist, macht die KI eigentlich irgendwas neu? Oder macht sie es noch einfacher? Ja.
Also ist das die Frage, die können wir auch zuspitzen, ist das das Ende von Hollywood oder das Ende von Michael Day?
Das wäre so deine Rubrik. Es geht ganz konkret nachher um Michael Day.
Oh, da bin ich gespannt.
Gut.
Wer das hören will, kann das ganz einfach tun mit einem Abo. Dann hat man natürlich auch Zugang zu allen Live-Salons, die schon erschienen sind und all den anderen Salons. Das ist möglich, wenn man auf die Seite neuzwanziger.de geht. Dort ist der Button hin zu Steady. Wenn man schon bei Patreon ist, kann man auch darüber buchen oder ganz bequem mit dem iPhone bei Apple.
Genau. So ist es. Wir hören uns.
Bis gleich.
Habt ihr es alle bequem? Ist es schön? Wer war mit uns gestern im Konzert? Ein paar Leute, ja, es war sehr voll. Dann ging es bis zwei Uhr nachts. Dann habe ich ein bisschen gechillt. Was hast du heute morgen gemacht?
Ich war im Städel und war mit Simone in der Normandie. Ja.
Du hast gesagt, es ist erhaben.
Ja.
Ich habe auch Stimmen gehört aus der hinten Ecke links, dass es nicht ganz so aufregend ist.
Doch. Die Erhabenheit ist ja das große Thema in der ästhetischen Theorie. Ich habe den Begriff natürlich nicht umsonst verwendet, denn es sind die Naturgewalten, denen Monet gegenübersteht an der Küste von Édretat. Er malt dort diese Felsen, malt die Wellen. Das ist eine Ausstellung, die nicht nur die Bilder zeigt von Monet, sondern auch alle im Künstlerkreis, so ein Dunskreis darum, wie das dann auch diese Landschaft geprägt hat, bis das dann auch einen touristischen Strom herbeigeführt hat. Und diese Erfahrung, wir als einzelne Menschen angesichts dieser Naturgewalten, das ist diese harben Erfahrung, die man machen kann, durch die man aber hindurchgehen muss, um dann zu einer Schönheit zu gelangen.
Okay, jetzt hast du gesagt Felsen, plural. Könnte es sein, dass auf jedem Bild derselbe Felsen ist?
Ja, also natürlich. Aber es ist so, dass wir es mit Studien darüber zu tun haben, wie man aus verschiedenen Perspektiven darauf blicken kann. Und man wird immer wieder etwas Neues sehen und wird andere Impressionen haben. Und man sieht dann, wie Monet sich ablöst quasi von dem, was man sagt, ich stelle das da, was ist. Sondern ich nehme sozusagen dann die Impressionen wortwörtlich und nehme es als Thema, aber drücke damit eigentlich innere Zustände auch aus.
Okay, das klingt wahnsinnig aufregend. Ich habe gestern ein Gespräch geführt mit jemandem, der sich auch die Ausstellung schon gesehen hat. Und meine Rückfrage war dann, die zwei großen Plakat-Drucke von außen am Städel, reichen die nicht?
Nein.
Die Antwort war so ein bisschen indifferent.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Es ist ja gerade in der Variation dann interessant.
Okay.
Also man geht da ja nicht in der Farbe. Man geht ja dann jetzt nicht hin, weil man sagt, ich schaffe es gerade nicht in die Normandie, also gehe ich in die Ausstellung. Das ist jetzt nicht der Grund, dass man sagt, es ist billiger im Städel, als jetzt extra in die Normandie ein Hotel zu buchen. Sondern man setzt sich ja quasi den Naturgewalten künstlerisch geläutert entgegen oder mit ihnen auseinander.
Okay. Als Städelmitglied bin ich natürlich verpflichtet, da auch noch hinzugehen. Es wird dann also auch von mir noch Impressionen geben.
Prima.
Okay.
Wir starten.
Wir starten kurz mit der Manufaktur dieses Podcasts, weil einige sind vielleicht zum ersten Mal hier. Typischerweise ist immer noch eine dritte Person hier im Raum. Olli, den grüßen wir aus der Ferne. Er ist auf Mallorca. Er muss arbeiten. Und er hält immer hier links vorne die Ecke frei. Weshalb mein Anhang heute, wie ich gehört hab, links hinten sitzt. Und jetzt werden wir aber zu doll geblendet. Und das Licht müsste nochmals so eingestellt werden, dass wir euch ein bisschen mehr sehen. Ja, sind wir noch ausreichend zu sehen für euch?
Nee, es ist vielleicht ein bisschen dunkle.
Okay, dann ist ein bisschen dunkel.
Ich glaube, wir müssen schon ein bisschen hochfahren.
Ja, gut, gut, gut, gut, gut.
Ich habe heute gemerkt, die Infrastruktur hatte erhebliche Probleme. Ich habe 40 Minuten gebraucht mit dem Uber. Also bis überhaupt mal ein Uber dann kam. Und dann wurde ich hier hingefahren, dachte mir, was ist los? Habe die Stadt natürlich gleich verantwortlich machen wollen, dass man einfach nichts mehr für den Autoverkehr in Frankfurt tut. Ihr kennt ja meine Reden.
Ja, da hören dir alle Parteien gerne zu.
Ja, fragte ich also dann den Uber-Fahrer, was ist denn eigentlich los? Und dann sagt er, ja, es fahren heute sehr viele Uber-Fahrer nicht, ein Großteil fährt nicht, denn Ramadan ist zu Ende. Und das war interessant, dass also damit wirklich diese Infrastruktur quasi zu mehr liegen kommt.
Ja, Uber ist in Frankfurt wesentliche Infrastruktur. Ja, darum musste man sich eigentlich anders kümmern. Aber jetzt ist die Kommunalwahl erstmal rum.
Ja, also es sei ja auch allen jetzt ein Abschluss gegönnt mit Zuckerfest und so weiter. Aber es war interessant zu sehen, wie schnell quasi dann so etwas, was eigentlich so immer funktioniert, nicht mehr funktionieren kann. Da sieht man wieder Relevanz. Ja, also die Relevanz, die systemrelevanten Jobs sind genau da, wo schlecht bezahlt wird.
Thema Nummer eins heute. Jürgen Habermas, wer kennt ihn? Muss auf was die Gegenprobe stellen. Wer kennt ihn nicht?
Okay, gut. Aber die meisten kennen ihn wohl doch. Also Jürgen Habermas ist jetzt im Alter von 96 Jahren verstorben. Wir würdigen jetzt diesen Philosophen auf eine etwas andere Art, denn du hast gesagt, du hättest dir da eine Sendung angehört. Ich hab sie mir dann nicht vorher in Vorbereitung angehört, sondern bin sehr gespannt, was du jetzt da herausarbeitest.
Das ist ganz verrückt. Also wir sind jetzt in so einem ganz reflexiven, wie auch immer. Wir machen einen Re-Entry auf mehreren Ebenen. Also wir versuchen, Paradoxien abzulösen, wie auch immer. Klingt alles sehr hochtrabend. Aber eigentlich sollte das nur ein kleines Thema sein. Angeblich ist Jürgen Habermas tot. So ein kleines Thema, das Jürgen Kaube nicht mal einen Nachruf geschrieben hat. Das ist ungefähr kurz vor der Hölle zu ist und so. Jetzt kann man nicht mal mehr an der FAZ nachlesen, was mit den Denkern ist.
Na ja, es gab ja viele andere Texte in der FAZ. Also es gab, also mir schienen das wirklich nochmal alle Zeitungen, also das fand ich doch sehr erstaunlich, dass wirklich nochmal das ganz große Rad gedreht wurde. Also Jürgen Habermas hat wirklich nochmal dazu geführt, dass nicht einfach ein großer Nachruf erscheint, sondern Weggefährten erinnern sich aus verschiedenen Perspektiven, die auch Habermas ausgemacht haben. Um das hier zu sagen, wir sitzen ja in Frankfurt. Also das ist ja kein unbedeutender Ort für Jürgen Habermas, auch wenn dann nachher am Starnberger See vorwiegend. Aber hier fing es ja quasi an, dann ging er eine Zeit lang nach Marburg, aber er ist ja nun ein Vertreter der Frankfurter Schule. Wo gleich jetzt der Streit beginnen könnte, ja, aber hat er nicht eigentlich die Ideale der Frankfurter Schule verraten. Das wollen wir jetzt heute, glaube ich, nicht alles hier auskramen.
Also ich habe ja kein Skin in the Game, da ich kein Habermass-Anhänger bin. Deswegen warte ich auf die Sprechakte von Format. Also mir ist schon wichtig, wer schreibt, die Autorität.
Ja.
Nützt mir gar nichts, wenn Herrschaftswei alle was über Habermass sagen. Und so habe ich eine Radiosendung gehört, die ich dann wütend ausgemacht habe, nachdem, aber dazu kommen wir im Verlaufe, diese kleine Parante, verart ich nicht. Also es ist SWR 2 Forum. Ich bin, oder es heißt gar nicht mehr SWR 2, sondern SWR Forum. Ich bin ja großer Fan. Ich habe es schon häufiger mitgebracht und die suchen ja immer gezielt zusammen, wer da so sitzt und spricht. Und in dem Falle, ich kenne sie alle gar nicht, Rahel Jaeggi.
Auch Frankfurter Schule. Ich glaube jetzt schon dann dritte, vierte Generation, würde man sagen. Ja. Dann Philipp Felsch hat dieses interessante Buch geschrieben, in der Lange Sommer der Theorie. Also über die Theorie, Produktion und Rezeption in den 60er, 70er, 80er Jahren.
Und Peter Neumann.
Zeit.
Genau. Es gibt ja noch einen anderen Peter Neumann, der macht am King's College irgendwas mit Terror. Aber das ist er nicht. Und diese drei Leute wurden also eingeladen im Radio. Und wir machen es jetzt so, wir framen das kurz, warum es für mich interessant ist, das jetzt mal zu hören. Es gibt viele Kritiker dieses Podcasts, die immer wieder kritisieren, wie ich über KI rede. Und Human hat ja, das habe ich ja schon angekündigt, eine Auswertung gemacht, in dem Sprechakte von mir aus den Transkripten und YouTube-Kommentare aus dem Fundus der letzten 5000 YouTube-Kommentare seit Juni, seit wir also einen eigenen Neuen Zwanziger YouTube-Account haben, gegeneinander spielt. Und darüber will ich gar nicht viel reden, aber das kann man selber nachlesen, denn ich habe es einfach veröffentlicht, also im Forum auf der Webseite könnt ihr das anklicken, für alle, die sich interessieren, für den Fall, dass mal jemand selber kommentiert hat. Am interessantesten finde ich, dass man jetzt immer reingeklastert wird. Man schreibt einen Kommentar und danach kann man bei uns, durch Olivia oder jetzt durch Human, nachlesen, in welches Lager man gehört. Also gehört man zu den inkonsistenten Links-Intellektuellen, also wer mir das vorwirft. Also es gibt die Gruppe, die mir vorwerfen, ein inkonsistenter Links-Ektueller zu sein. Oder Leute, die den epistemischen Verfall des Podcasts bemängeln. Außerdem KI als Klassenwerkzeug der Superreichen, da kann man ja nicht einfach mitspielen, der kompetente Praktiker gegen den naiven Enthusiasten gibt es natürlich auch, ist ja klar und grün markiert, weil positiv das Narrativ Nummer 5, KI als normales Werkzeug im Alltag. Da würde ich mich jetzt mal so grob reinzählen. Also wer so kommentiert, ist sozusagen auf meiner Seite.
Und wo komme ich da noch vor?
Du kommst in dieser Analyse hier gar nicht vor, da wir ja gesagt haben, es geht spezifisch darum.
Ich dachte da kommt jetzt noch so eine Rubrik hoffnungsloser Romantiker oder irgendwie sowas.
Also wir veröffentlichen natürlich nicht das, also das Datenmaterial ist ja veröffentlicht. Alle YouTube Kommentare sind verfügbar, die Transkripte auch. Man könnte Wolfgangs naive Fragen der letzten Monate zum Thema auch nochmal ausmachen. Jetzt sozusagen hier mal gucken, was da los ist seit Leute irgendwie unterstellen, dass ich gesagt hätte, Absinth frisst Babys oder so. Und das war das Original Zitat. Also man muss es gar nicht so hochtramend aufhängen. Aber wenn man es hochtramend aufhängt, schreibt man halt schnell mal Kommentare. Und das kann man jetzt sozusagen fangen jetzt nicht wieder damit an. Nein, dann fangen wir jetzt nicht an, sondern wir machen jetzt den großen Kontrapunkt dazu. Wie sähe der Podcast aus? Würden wir auf die Kritik hören, auf sie eingehen und das Gespräch zu unseren Themen grundsätzlich? Und KI ist ja ein andauerndes Thema. Neuformen. Und jetzt sind wir sozusagen in dieser paradoxen Falle, dass Habermas gestorben ist. Leute im Radio darüber reden, wie der Typ, der über Kommunikation geschrieben hat, zu besprechen ist, mit Hilfe von Kommunikation. Und wir nutzen mal diesen kleinen Auszug als Einstieg.
Da würde ich mich Frau Jaeggi unbedingt anschließen. Was mit Habermas hier zu Ende geht, geht ja schon länger zu Ende. Wir beobachten, und nicht zuletzt hat Habermas das beobachtet.
So, inhaltlicher wird es nachher nur in einem Clip, denn wir sind ja auf dieser Methodenebene. Wie wird da gesprochen? Also, da würde sich der Herr Dings, der Frau Jaeggi, mal anschließen. Was mit Habermas zu Ende ging, ging ja schon länger zu Ende. Und ich würde gerne darauf hinweisen, Habermas hat eine kritische Theorie geschrieben. Die ist kritisch, weil sie einen sehr negativen Umgang mit dem hat, was Habermas beobachtete. Und was Habermas nicht gut fand, ist, wenn Leute im Radio saßen, weil das ja bedeutete, dass sehr viele nicht im Radio sitzen, sondern vor dem Radio sitzen, die also schon allein durch eine Machtasymmetrie, sie haben kein Mikrofon, man hört auf sie nicht, zur Passivität gezwungen sind. Da ist auf jeden Fall jetzt kein herrschaftsfreies Diskurs auf der Suche nach dem besten Argument und so weiter möglich. Das herrlich geht fürs Fernsehen. Und wie wir ja jetzt, das ist ja die zweite große Enttäuschung.
Das konsumierende Publikum nur.
Genau.
Das Resonierende.
Und dann kam ja irgendwann das Internet auf und dann kam die zweite große Enttäuschung, über die Habermas selber noch mal geschrieben hat. Wir haben sehr aufgegriffen. Plötzlich wieder nur irgendwelche Milliardäre, die sagen, wer ein Mikrofon bekommt.
Naja, also die Pointe seines letzten Textes, also nicht, das war nicht sein letzter Text, aber sein Update zum Strukturwandel der Öffentlichkeit, auf den du jetzt eben angespielt hast, war ja, dass er sagte, bei allen Problemen, die dieses System, das ich im Strukturwandel der Öffentlichkeit beschrieben habe, mit sich bringt, muss ich doch nun angesichts der Plattformen und der dort wüsten Geräusche, die entstehen aufgrund dieser User, die einfach alles hinausschreien und alles hineintippen, sagen, dass dieses Gatekeeper-System doch wohl auch Vorteile hatte und damit auch diese Passivität immerhin ja dafür sorgte, dass eben die Leute zwar konsumieren konnten, aber nicht auch noch aus so einer Präsigkeit heraus dann noch mal irgendwelche Beleidigungen oder sonst was da reinschreiben konnte oder irgendwelchen Unsinn erzählen. Und da war jetzt seine Idee, dass ja dann doch eine gewisse Qualitätssicherung runtergebrochen stattfand durch dieses System, das er in den 60er-Jahren kritisiert hat. Was aber dann bedeuten würde, und so ist das ja auch dann gemeint, dass eigentlich er will, dass die Plattformen wie Redaktionen behandelt werden. Bedeutet also, er will eigentlich, dass dieses Amendment 230, das jetzt gerade auch in den USA strittig ist, angegriffen wird. Und was auch hier ja viele fordern, dass diese Plattformen dieses Privileg verlieren, dass das tatsächlich, also im Habermaschen Sinne ist, dass die das verlieren, weil man dann wieder ein System hat der Qualitätssicherung und der Gatekeeper-Funktion, was aber dann bedeutet, dass das freie Internet auch tot ist, weil das ursprünglich einmal dazu gemacht worden ist. Wir haben ja schon häufiger über diese Thematik gesprochen. Aber das ist interessant, dass also jetzt Habermas, wenn man so möchte, diese Kehrtwende macht, dass er sich mit Corporate Media und den öffentlich-rechtlichen und so weiter plötzlich publizistisch verbündete und sagte, naja, eigentlich ist das jetzt ein noch viel schlimmeres Problem, dann ist mir die alte Welt doch noch lieber, die ich vorher kritisiert habe.
Genau. Und das kann man sehr gut unterbrechen, denn die Radiotheorie von Berthold Brecht ist so eine Art Zündfunken für die CED. Also 1932 sagt Brecht, der Rundfunk ist aus einem Distributionsapparat in einen Kommunikationsapparat zu verwandeln, was nur dadurch klappt, dass jeder Empfänger auch gleichzeitig ein Sender sein könnte. Und das ist ja schon die Idee, die dann im Internet so geboren wurde, aber sich nicht verwirklichte und bis dahin wurde eben noch das Fernsehen erfunden. Habermas legt dann 1962 seinen Strukturwandel der Öffentlichkeit vor, spricht davon, wenn die Massenmedien jetzt wieder zuteilen, wer reden darf, haben es mit einer Re-Feudalisierung zu tun, also ganz großes Vokabular. Und Hans Magnus Enzensberger hat dann in seinem Baukasten zu einer Theorie der Moderne ganz konkret auf die Radiotheorie verwiesen und die ganze Frankfurter Schule und diese Habermas-Denke da mitgebracht und es ergibt sich eigentlich so ein großes Konglomerat, bei dem man, finde ich, immer in diesem Problem drinsteckt. Wenn man im Radio über Habermas spricht, muss man eigentlich kurz anmerken, ich weiss jetzt nicht auf, man muss seine Privilegien kurz checken und deutlich machen, aber man sitzt halt wirklich gerade im Radio so und das weiß man auch in dem Moment. Was aber stattfindet und das fand ich halt super interessant, die sitzen in dem Radio-Studio, blenden das Publikum aus, statt es zu ermächtigen und cosplayen aber innerhalb ihrer kleinen Interaktion, dass sie jetzt hier ganz herrschaftsfrei diskutieren. Und dazu möchte ich diese Beispiele bringen, weil es einfach albern ist zu machen. Fangen wir mal hier an bei Herrn Felsch.
Ich finde das, wenn ich mich kurz einmischen darf, finde das sehr sympathisch, dass wir hier vielleicht auch ein bisschen den radikalen Habermas nochmal freilegen.
Der radikale Habermas wird freigelegt, indem man kurz anzeigt, wenn ich mich nochmal einmischen darf in das Gespräch, in das ich, ja, jetzt können wir mal überlegen, darf er sich einmischen? Ich meine, der Radiosender hat ihn eingeladen, hat ihm die Reise bezahlt, hat ihm dieses Mikro eingeschaltet, hat gesagt, jetzt geht's los. Meinst du, er darf sich einmischen, oder? Also, das ist Soziologie Cosplay, was ja auch mir gerne vorgeworfen wird. Von Leni ist sie hier. Also, ich gebe heute den Cosplay-Vorwurf an die anderen wieder zurück. Ja, hier ein Beispiel. Das nächste, Neumann.
Strukturen, die man nicht außer Acht lassen darf.
Also, ich würde da gerne nochmal einhaken, bei der Frage der deutschen Einheit und der Verfassung. Da würde ich widersprechen.
Ich glaube. So, jetzt muss sich jeder überlegen. Was ist einem lieber, dass ich im Podcast einfach sage, sorry, aber du irrst dich. Das ist total absurd. Oder, also ich würde gerne nochmal einhaken, bei der Frage der deutschen Einheit. Ich würde dann widersprechen, soll ich noch meinen Sprechakt anmelden?
So kann ich dann auch machen.
Ja, genau. Also, es ist wirklich absurd. Und so ging das diese ganze Sendung lang.
Ein realer und wirklich spürbarer Mangel.
Ja, aber ich finde auch, da würde ich auch Herrn Neumann zustimmen.
Aber ja, geht es dann wieder weiter? Doch nicht. Und so. Also es ist im Grunde, die sind die ganze Zeit auf der Ebene, was ich ja gar nicht mag, wenn irgendwelche Leute in eine thematische Diskussion diese Beziehungsebene reinbringen. Also heute ging es ja am aufwachen Podcast wieder zur Sache. Verstehen sich Hans und Stefan eigentlich? Hält Wolfgang noch lange mit Stefan aus und so?
Das ist eine Frage, ja. Die Sache ist ja die, dass hier ein kultiviertes Gespräch, ich würde sagen, simuliert wird. Bedeutet, wir reden jetzt darüber, wie die eigentlich sich verschanzen hinter den Gepflogenheiten des guten Gesprächs, um zu sagen, wir machen hier noch den Diskurs, den Habermas eins wollte. Allerdings jetzt hier am Radio, du hast es gesagt, ein bisschen schwierig.
Da, wo es genau nicht geht?
Wenn wir jetzt diese Ebene verlassen, dann müsste man sagen, was wäre die Alternative? Wäre die radikale Konfrontation?
Genau. Ich würde sagen, umformuliert, die nicht Zeitverschwendung. Man hat eine dreiviertel Stunde, das Publikum möchte etwas wissen. Und was ich nicht wissen möchte, ist, ob jemand es geschafft hat, sich kurz diesen Satz nochmal zu erkämpfen, mit fünf Sätzen einleitend würde, hätte, könnte, wollte, also eigentlich wollte ich mal und so. Aber erstmal schließe ich nochmal danksagend an den Vorredner an.
Hin und wieder nimmt man ja auch Anlauf durch solche Sätze. Man neigt dazu.
Das wäre große Kunst, wenn das hier vorgekommen wäre. Also wenn irgendwo eine inhaltliche Pointe da wäre, hätte ich die mitgebracht. Ja, also eine kommt nachher. Aber so jetzt kommt ein Highlight-Clip. Es ist wirklich genial. Aber wenn ich da vielleicht nochmal einhaken darf, ich würde diese Hellsichtigkeit eben eigentlich nur zum Teil unterschreiben wollen. Also wenn ich da nochmal einhaken, also einhaken ist schon problematisch, also muss ich um Erlaubnis bitten, darf ich würde diese Hellsichtigkeit, Lob für den Vorredner, irgendwer war ganz hellsichtig, eben eigentlich nur zum Teil unterschreiben, also schon Zustimmung wollen.
Die Frage ist ja hier, wer ist der große andere, für den man das aufführt? Ist das das Publikum oder ist das Jürgen Habermas, den man eigentlich noch meint, dass er dort sitzt und am Ende Noten vergebt?
Er ist ja tot, er hört das ja nicht mehr. Man kann hier nicht mehr, und das ist ja immer die Unterstellung, die Hospitanten kommen in die FAZ, um dann für ihren Professor nochmal zu schreiben, um dem Professor zu zeigen, ich habe richtig gut aufgepasst, hier, zack, ist der Text. Nur er ist ja tot. Also der große andere, der einzige, den es noch interessiert, nein, das war jetzt zu scharf. Es gibt schon noch ein paar Leute, die wollen sowas, also die möchten gerne, dass so diskutiert wird. Habermass, wie gesagt, würde ich sagen, wurde selber am Ende dann missverstanden, weil Leute von ihren eigenen See- und Sprechgewohnheiten nicht abrücken wollten. Also das kann man ja auch bis sonst in Endlich führen. Aber dass hier sechsmal vorsichtig, anmerkend und so weiter und dann irgendwann mal ein Punkt kommt, das ist einfach bescheuert. Und das darf ich aber nicht sagen, sondern ich würde schon sagen, das ist vielleicht nicht ganz so überzeugend.
Ja, darf ich noch einen Satz? Nur, ich glaube, Herr Neumann, wir sind uns einig. Habermas war sehr borniert.
So, darf ich noch einen Satz? Okay. Wir sind uns ja einig. Okay. Aber.
Das ist ja eine Erfahrung, die wir wahrscheinlich alle gemacht haben, die wir an Universitäten waren, wenn wir an Universitäten waren und vielleicht irgendwelche Konferenzen besucht haben, dass das schon eine Art des Sprechens dort ist, die vorherrschend ist. Womit man eigentlich schon sagt, wir müssen hier uns als Festung verstehen, dichten uns durch solches Vokabular und durch solche Rhetoriken ab. Aber die großen Probleme finden nicht mehr statt. Die große Auseinandersetzung, der Kampf, der Streit findet nicht statt. Weshalb dann ja ist so Leute, um jetzt mal in ganz anderes Extrem zu gehen, wie Charlie Kirk, so einfach hatten, an Universitäten richtig den Zirkusdirektor zu spielen. Weil die einfach dahingehen und all in, wie du sagen würdest, gehen. Und dann ist plötzlich Aufregung da, was dann da an dem Campus los. Oder man hat es jetzt auch gerade erfahren, Schloss Elmau, da wurde getagt, die Ivan Krastov hat die Konferenzen organisiert zum Thema Ist die Demokratie am Ende? So und etwa. Viele waren eingeladen aus dem bekannten liberalen, linksliberalen, mitedemokratischen Spektrum und Curtis Jarvin, der also der extreme Rechte ist. Was dann bedeutete, dass natürlich nur Artikel darüber erschienen sind. Wie war er denn? Weil überhaupt dadurch, dass so ein anderes Sprechen da stattfinden könnte, alle alarmiert waren und plötzlich Journalisten aus aller Herren Länder angereist sind, um das Spektakel zu erleben, dass dann keines wurde. Denn, wie man hörte, es gibt keine Aufzeichnung, zumindest habe ich keine gefunden, hat Jarvin sich genauso verhalten wie die anderen auch und hat also resonierend langsam auf dem Podium geredet und hat gerade nicht das getan, was er sonst tut, zu provozieren. Woraufhin dann in der FAZ Harald Staun schrieb, na ja, so inhaltlich war er eigentlich Peter Sloterdijk Provokator.
Ja, ich habe eine ganz tolle E-Mail bekommen, mit der du von Charlie Kirk sprichst. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das jetzt vorlesen darf. Ich würde so gerne, ich umreiße kurz. Also es wurde eine Hausarbeit geschrieben, eine Bachelorarbeit. Die wurde super gut bewertet. Man könnte sie nicht besser bewerten. Es hat für Aufsehen gesorgt. Und am Lehrstuhl war man schon der Meinung, diese Arbeit sollte man mal Jürgen Habermas zeigen. Woraufhin der Autor, ein junger Student, aber schrieb, mich würde viel mehr interessieren, was du dazu denkst.
Stefan, ich gratuliere dir.
Falls ihr euch fragt, wie man mich erreicht per E-Mail, man muss nur richtige E-Mails schreiben.
Ja, Stefan, also du siehst, die Fußstapfen sind relativ groß, aber du könntest hineintreten. Gerade hier in Frankfurt.
Genau, ich möchte kurz darauf hinweisen, ich muss auf den Autor eh noch mal zugehen, denn es ist ja eine nicht publizierte Bachelorarbeit, über die wir auf jeden Fall sprechen müssen. Denn den Titel darf ich glaube ich verraten, damit verraten.
Meinst du?
Viel, ich weiß nicht genau.
Ja, lass es vielleicht.
Es geht um den Herrn Hegemon.
Den Herrn Hegemon?
Es steht fast der Herr Hegemon so im Titel. Es ist genau uns...
Sicher dich vorher noch mal ab, bevor wir hier schon Ergebnisse vorwegnehmen.
Graue Literatur schickt uns doch am besten, wie soll man sagen, wir kriegen zu viel Zusendung von Sachen, die publiziert sind, aber nicht der Rede wert. Und ab und zu kriegen wir Sachen, die absolut der Rede wert sind, aber leider nicht publiziert sind. Und das ist dann schwierig. Das erste Mal in zehn Jahren, dass ich Podcasts mache und eine höhere Sache kriege, bei der ich nicht genau weiß, wie man damit umgehen soll. Gut, zurück zum Text. Wir hören den nächsten Clip, der erste Satz. Ich lese ihn danach noch mal vor, ist, das ist einfach bescheuert.
Was hier eigentlich schief läuft.
Aber wenn ich da kurz einhaken darf, jetzt für dich, das sehe ich genauso. Und das ist aber trotzdem natürlich auch eine Abivalenz, die in seinem Zugriff auf das philosophische Denken steckt.
So, aber wenn ich da noch mal kurz einhaken darf, um zu sagen, ich sehe das genauso, es gibt also gar keinen Grund einzuhaken, das ist aber trotzdem natürlich auch eine Abivalenz. Das ist, warum läuft es quasi so umständlich die Tür.
Naja, ich will es jetzt mal ganz böse sagen. Sehr viel der Theorieproduktion der vergangenen drei Jahrzehnte, würde ich vier Jahrzehnte sagen, funktioniert dadurch, dass man solche Sätze konstruiert. Wenn man es dann wegnehmen würde, würde nur noch sehr wenig auf dem Platt Papier stehen. Also ich unterstelle wirklich, dass es so eine Theorieproduktion gibt, um der Theorieproduktion wegen. Jetzt haben wir ja noch nicht viel von ihr gehört, aber ich stelle das mitunter auch bei, ich weiß, ich verärgere einige, bei Rahel Jaeggi fest. Das wäre also einfach eine Philosophie, die mich dann doch am Ende nicht interessiert. Und ich kaufe sehr viele Sachbücher im Theoriebände im Jahr und lese 20 Seiten und lege sie sofort weg. Also ich gehe immer noch rein, bin aber mittlerweile auch dazu übergangen, wirklich bei den Leseproben im Internet hängen zu bleiben und denke, ich kann, ich vertrage es nicht. Also es ist ja, es ist, es ist so, es ist diese Art der Theorieproduktion und nochmal sich da und dort abdichten. Und vielleicht haben wir dann nochmal eine Polyvalenz, bei der wir aber auch nochmal schauen, ob da diskursiv was unterminiert wird, wo ich sage, nee, das klingt jetzt auch so anti-intellektualistisch. Aber was ich einfach damit meine ist, dass man in gewisser Weise so ein Fabulieren produziert hat, bei dem man eigentlich in einem ewigen Gespräch miteinander bleiben kann. Aber dabei hat man das andere eigentlich übersehen. Und das ist, glaube ich, eine Kritik, die man auch durchaus Habermas machen kann. Bei allem, was er auch, finde ich, Sinnvolles getan hat, dass er schon sehr mit seiner Theorie des kommunikativen Handels in einen Bereich gegangen ist, wo er eigentlich nur noch so ein Verwalter war von, wie sprechen wir miteinander, hat aber die eigentlichen großen ökonomischen Umbrüche, inklusive dem Neoliberalismus, weder kommen sehen noch konnte er sich eigentlich da interessant zu positionieren, außer auf einem moderat technokratischen Wege weiterhin zu sagen, lasst uns das, was wir haben jetzt hier schützen, und können wir es mitunter noch ein bisschen sozialdemokratisch unterfüttern. Aber ich finde, dass zum Beispiel keine fundamentale Kritik eines finanzialisierten Kapitalismus kam. Ich sehe das einfach bei Habermas nicht, sondern ich sehe einfach, dass es dann auch zu Recht ein Philosophar, der von Technokraten wie Macron sich einverleibt wurde. Und das liegt sehr daran, weil man sagt, wir können darüber im Gespräch bleiben. Aber wenn wir dann über die eigentliche Macht reden, dann verstummen wir. Und ich will das noch mal zuspitzen. Wir haben sehr viele Leute gehabt im Klimadiskurs der 2017er-, 18er-, 19er-Jahre, die sich mit Transformationen aller Arten beschäftigt haben und auch so ein Habermasches Ideal dann dabei hatten. Deshalb ja auch diese ganze Bürgerart, die Ideen dann immer kamen. Jetzt kann Habermas nicht für jeden Epigon etwas, aber ich will einfach diese Tradition sagen, was dann dazu führte, dass man einfach die großen Machtverhältnisse, einfach die Frage, wollen die USA, die unsere Partner damals waren, wirklich, dass wir energieautonom werden oder nicht? Dass man diese Frage überhaupt nicht sich stellt, sondern man nur die Frage stellt, wie können wir wen, wo, wann überzeugen mit dem besseren Argument im herrschaftsfreien Diskurs? Und das geht einfach an der Sache vorbei und das ärgert mich sehr. Es wurde sehr viel Zeit mit Reden verbracht, ohne etwas zu sagen und das klingt nach einer Platitüne. Es stimmt aber leider.
Ja, also du sagst zu Recht, man hätte sehr viel streiten müssen. Auf der inhaltlichen Ebene, wenn man die nicht erreicht, wenn man die ganze Zeit hier ein Habermass-Cosplay macht, hört sich richtiger Streit so an.
Ja, zerknirscht und auch vielleicht ein bisschen verzweifelt zurücklassen.
Ich glaube, man muss ganz kurz, man muss, glaube ich, unbedingt die USA noch erwähnen.
Ich glaube, und dann hat die andere auch schon, ich glaube, gesagt und dann waren beide, mussten kurz aushalten, nur kurz, ja, ja, okay, alles klar. Ich ziehe zurück. So und ich glaube, ich glaube, unbedingt man muss irgendwas machen. Natürlich noch mal Amerika erwähnen, warum auch nicht. Das Land ist ja groß und wichtig. Hier Nissa.
Wir haben ja zum Glück, wir postmodernen Kinder der 90er Jahre, wenn ich das für mich sagen darf, wir haben ja zum Glück auch, um es mit Habermass zu sagen, einen Lernprozess hinter uns.
So, das ist wirklich sehr gut, denn wir haben ja zum Glück, und dann kommt ein Verweis auf sich selber, wir postmodernen Kinder der 90er, also wenn ich das für mich sagen darf, und man denkt sich so, kommt jetzt endlich der Sprechakt von ihm selber, hat er sich ausreichend freigekämpft, kann jetzt der Punkt kommen, und dann verweist er, um es mit Habermass zu sagen. Zieht sich also genau wieder auf die Autorität zurück.
Ein Leben in Referenzen.
Also, dass Habermass noch mal als Autorität missbraucht wird von Leuten, die im Radio über herrschaftsfreien Diskurs diskutieren, ist einfach witzig, finde ich.
Absolut, ja.
Neumann.
Das steht uns vielleicht heute auch deutlich vor Augen.
Das würde ich unbedingt auch noch mal unterstreichen wollen, weil das war ja auch unter anderem eines der Kernanliegen eigentlich seines Spätwerkes, auch eine Geschichte der Philosophie, gewissermaßen die Genealogie dieser Lernprozesse zu rekonstruieren.
Ja, also so führt man den Diskurs nach vorne, indem man sagt, das, was gerade gesagt wurde, muss unbedingt von mir auch noch mal unbedingt unterstrichen werden, um darauf hinzuweisen, dass ich auch verstanden habe, dass es hier in diesem Spätwerk durchaus um eine Geschichte der Philosophie, wenn nicht um die Rekonstruktion der Genealogie eines Lernprozesses ging.
Ja, auch eine Geschichte der Philosophie ist ja das letzte große Opus magnum von Jürgen Habermas und dem ja quasi Philosophie und Religionsphilosophie so, ich habe es nicht gelesen, aber so örtlich sind Rezensionen, hinleitet, dass man am Ende bei ihm herauskommt, was natürlich sehr geschickt ist, dass man die abendgleichliche Geschichte quasi so auf ihn zulaufen lässt. Aber was ich hier nochmal ausdrücke, ich sage mal, denn wir haben ja mitunter solche Gespräche, wo ich das Menschliche retten muss und ich habe ein bisschen den Verdacht, ich muss heute Abend nochmal tun vor der KI. Da hilft uns natürlich Habermas sehr. Er hat sich ja wirklich sehr intelligent eingemischt in die intellektuellen Debatten zum Thema Eugenik, zum Thema Transhumanismus, nennt man es heute. Damals hatte man noch andere Begriffe dafür. Er hat also da eigentlich die entscheidenden Texte geliefert, auch mit einer großen Sorge tatsächlich. Und da hat er sehr viel antizipieren können, was er im wirtschaftlichen Bereich eher nicht getan hat. Aber da sind wichtige Texte entstanden, wo er wirklich das Subjekt versucht zu retten, nicht nur, sondern auch wirklich den den Mensch, die Kondition humaner.
Also ich bin über die Jahre ein sehr großer Habermass-Freund geworden, viel größer als damals in Bielefeld. Es war super witzig, dass Klaus Japp, also ein wirklich großer orthodoxer Luhmann-Interpret, uns dann noch vorgeworfen hat, dass wir zu schlecht über Habermass sprechen. Und heute, und es klingt jetzt ein bisschen despiktierlich, aber es ist wirklich verrückt, manche Luhmannschen Texte aus ihrer Zeit, und du sagst ja immer, die sind sehr zeitabhängig, da würde ich komplett widersprechen, aber in der Didaktik, der Aneignung, versteht man manche Sachen sehr viel besser, wenn man weiß, was Habermas zur Zeit, also zur selben Zeit publizierte, um dann einfach eine Kontur herauszufinden. Und da muss man natürlich dann schon beides so ein bisschen lesen, aber halt gegen Habermas. Nicht die ganze Zeit hier nochmal, darf ich sie nochmal hufieren, und hier nochmal, das war ja super toll, und diesen Cosplay die ganze Zeit machen. Und jetzt, und das ist so strange, wir sind in Minute 41 von diesem 45-Minuten-Gespräch, und plötzlich sagt die Jaeggi...
Und das scheint mir doch, wie gesagt, man kann das mit ganz anderen Theoremen konstruieren. Es gibt viele Hinsichten, in denen ich sagen würde, da würde ich nicht anschließen. Ich finde auch, dass in vielen entscheidenden Dingen Habermass im Grunde, also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel die Theorie des kommunikativen Handelns angucken, die Frage, welche Art von Gesellschaftstheorie eine solche kritische Theorie der Emanzipation eigentlich haben sollte, die ist in der Theorie des kommunikativen Handelns auf radikale Weise gestellt, auf radikale Weise auch beantwortet worden. Sehr, sehr viele, ich gehöre dazu, lehnen das, was sich da im Ende als Dualismus von System und Lebenswelt herauskristallisiert hat, als theoretische Position ab. Aber man muss auch sagen, auf dem Niveau hat seitdem auch niemand wieder, sozusagen, darauf geantwortet oder das weiterentwickelt oder das überwunden. Insofern hat er so viele Fragen gestellt, die im Grunde, die uns begleiten werden, die offen sind, die auch zum Teil liegen gelassen worden sind, zum Teil auch von ihm selbst.
Ich möchte dich dekodieren. Das ist wirklich das, was wir gerade gehört haben, ist das Absurdeste, was ich zum Thema Soziologie im Radio oder sonst wo gehört habe. Also, die reden jetzt 90 Prozent in diesem Gespräch, dreht sich im Grunde um dieses Erarbeiten von, darf ich hier mal was sagen und so weiter. Da kommt im Grunde nichts außer, Habermass hat auch mal was zur deutschen Wende gesagt und zur Amerika. Der war sehr enttäuscht und biografisch am Anfang großer Amerika-Freund. Und dann hat sich das plötzlich nicht ergeben und so weiter und so fort. So, und dann werden die inhaltlich und dann sagt sie einfach, nachdem die die ganze Zeit Methoden-Cosplay Habermas machen, auf eine Art und Weise, bei der Habermas als Zuhörer gesagt hätte, sorry, aber das ist ja, ich verstehe so langsam, warum es nicht aufging, also warum dieser Menschheit, meine Menschheit nicht zu machen ist. So, und dann wird sie inhaltlich und sagt, ja, eigentlich jetzt, wo ich drüber nachdenke, also dieses Fundamentale, hier nochmal die Lebenswelt zu unterscheiden in so einem Dualismus von den Systemen. Das ist gar nicht so tragfähig. Man denkt sich so, ja, also das Denkangebot dazu auf entsprechendem Niveau gibt es seit du selbst geboren bist.
Und wir ahnen, was jetzt kommt.
Ich will es ehrlich auskühlen, aber dass mein, ja, du meinst, du bist der Einzige, der die Gegenangebote gemacht hat. Also das Normative, Idealistische ein bisschen raus, dass wir alle einfach in einem dauerhaften Gespräch miteinander und so weiter, das ist vielleicht gar nicht so zielführend. So, aber es gab wirklich sehr viel Angebot. Habermas ist dann nicht der Einzige. Und diesen Abschied, den sie hier ziemlich radikal, finde ich, von diesem ganzen Theoriegebote, weil sie mir das Fundament nimmt, einfach noch mal so einzustreuen, also ich verstehe das gar nicht, noch weniger, also hier nehmen ja Leute Habermas ernst, indem sie uns vorgaukeln, ihn ernst zu nehmen. Aber ich würde sagen, ich nehme Habermas viel ernster als sie, weil sie das die ganze Zeit so affirmativ macht. Das ist ja ganz toll, was der Habermas gemacht hat. Es stimmt aber nur nicht. Aber es ist trotzdem superschön. Und ich sage, naja, es ist nicht besonders schön und es stimmt auch nicht, aber man kann doch super damit arbeiten. Das ist ja wie in so einem Bergwerk, wo man halt einfach einen Steinhaufen findet, aber man kann zumindest ein cooles Haus daraus bauen. Nur hier befindet man einfach einen Steinhaufen und sagt dann, ja, aber es wäre schon cooler, wenn es echter Marmor wäre. Also es ist eigentlich so ein Werturteil. Also dieser Dualismus gefällt mir da nicht. Es ist wirklich absurd.
Wir haben ja von Peter Sloterdijk irgendwann mal einen Clip gespielt, darin bezeichnete er Jürgen Habermas als Zyklenmeister der Papa-Phrase. Also womit er eigentlich andeuten will, dass er kein origineller Denker und so. Tadeik nimmt natürlich für sich in Anspruch, der originellen Denker zu sein. Das lassen wir mal so stehen.
Ja, das stimmt doch, oder?
Naja, er ist der böse Denker. Ich glaube, er ist ja der, der aus der Tradition Nietzsche heraus schreibt und die Bevölkerung oder sagen wir die Öffentlichkeit wachrutschen will mit irgendetwas oder provozieren will. Man könnte heute auch modern sagen, trollen will. Das ist etwas, was jetzt Jürgen Habermas vollkommen fernliegen würde, weshalb er ja auch damals diesen großen Streit hatte, beziehungsweise interveniert hatte, indirekt interveniert hatte, als Regeln für den Menschenpark von Sloterdijk diese Rede gehalten wurde, in der er ja das transhumanistische Projekt eigentlich schon andeutet, über Selektion nachdenkt, in einer Weise, wo man sich natürlich fragen konnte, gibt er den Diskurs einfach wieder oder plädiert er genau für das? Jedenfalls hat man ja damals, wie Sloterdijk sagte, von einem einsamen Faxgerät am Starnberger Seehaus, diesen Skandal dann entfacht und hat also sehr viele Leute in Anschlag gebracht gegen Sloterdijk. Aber das ist genau das nicht, was wir bei Habermas finden, ist, dass er mal irgendeine Provokation macht. Seine Intervention beim Krieg in der Ukraine, die ja hohe Wellen geschlagen hat, war ja gerade eines nicht provokativ, sondern er war ja gerade der, der abwägend wie kein anderer war. Was bedeutete, er war plötzlich der Provokante, der Troll, weil niemand mehr abgewägt hat und ruhig war. Während er sonst immer so zum Mäßigen aufrief, wo die anderen sagten, und jetzt Occupy Wall Street oder sonst was, kam dann von Habermas ein unglaublich komplizierter Text über EZB, Europa, Technokratie und so weiter. Aber er war jetzt genau in dieser Rolle, in der er eigentlich in den letzten Jahrzehnten war, plötzlich die absolute Provokation für die, die sagten, jetzt aber mal alle an die Front.
Ja, wie wäre es mal mit einem anderen Argument? Na, bloß nicht. Das sind die großen Interventionen. Was eben bedeutet, also politisch, ist ja Thema unseres Podcasts, da liegt ja alles, alles ein Krott auf dem Boden. Der theoretische Überbau wird jetzt der Rede von Leuten, die dann irgendwann nach 45 Minuten, also am Ende des Gesprächs feststellen, dass eigentlich alles gar nicht richtig zusammenpasst. Und dann bleibt natürlich nur, dass man da noch mal zustimmen muss.
Bleibt Habermas Werk, wenn ich Frau Jaeggi richtig verstanden habe, in gewisser Weise unabgeschlossen?
Natürlich. Insofern ist es über sich hinausweist. Ich glaube, der Impuls, da kann ich Frau Jaeggi nur zustimmen, der Impuls dieses Theorieuniversums bleibt uns auf der einen Seite eine Gesellschaftstheorie, eine kritische Gesellschaftstheorie, die die Wirklichkeit im Licht ihrer Möglichkeiten beschreibt, auch wenn wir diese Möglichkeiten jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr in den positiven Einzeldisziplinen suchen, sondern vielleicht sogar auch so etwas wie Transzendenz wieder zulassen, wie Metaphysik oder Religion. Also wir suchen vielleicht in anderen Richtungen, aber diese Suche können wir nicht aufgeben.
Ja, das ist im Grunde die Flosge, die kennt jeder, gut gemeint. Nur, dass die eigenen größten Anhänger und Freunde am Ende einfach sagen, er war gut gemeint. Finde ich schon wirklich bedauerlich, denn die Kritik darf ruhig ein bisschen klüger sein. Im Finale, finde ich, wird alles aus Versehen schön zusammengebunden.
Das war unser Forum zum Thema Philosoph der Vernunft. Was bleibt von Jürgen Habermas?
Ja, der Philosoph der Vernunft. Also für alle, die sich jetzt fragen, worüber haben die gerade geredet? Ich habe Stefan nicht verstanden, keine Ahnung. Ich möchte darauf hinweisen, dieser Vernunftbegriff, also abgeleitet aus so Idealvorstellungen, die man hat und das müsste doch eigentlich jeder einsehen. Frieden ist gut, Freiheit ist gut, dafür sollten wir kämpfen und so weiter. Das läuft ja alles unter Vernunft. Und das wurde eben im Streit mit Habermas damals von Theorieanbietern, die die Frau Jaeggi hier irgendwie nicht kennt oder wie auch immer, auf sehr hohem Niveau gesagt. Ne, wir machen jetzt keine Vernunft mehr. Wir streichen die Vernunft einfach aus unserem Wortschatz. Grundbegriff ist nicht mehr. Und wir setzen an die Stelle anderes wie zum Beispiel Rationalität, aber immer im Plural. Jeder bringt seine eigene Rationalität mit, was eben auch bedeutet, niemand muss sich hier reinkämpfen in einen Diskurs, weil doch für jeden klar ist, dass der andere eine andere Rationalität mitbringt und nicht noch mal seine Sicht auf Vernunft den anderen erst mal als Fundament reindrügeln muss, und dann man die ganze Zeit auf diesem Floskeltheater bleibt.
Verloren geht dabei natürlich die Ermächtigung des Subjekts, die bei Habermass, auch wenn er sagen wir etwas angepasst dann irgendwann war, immer noch da war. Also die Emanzipation im wirklich weitesten Sinne und im engsten Sinne ist dann nicht mehr gegeben.
Ne, genau, umgedreht. Wir haben eben nicht mehr die eine Vernunft, und dann ist das Subjekt egal, weil die Vernunft, sondern wir haben ein Subjekt, das bringt eine eigene Rationalität mit. Und diese Rationalität ist an dieses Subjekt gekoppelt, ungestört von einem höheren Gut, einer Vernunft, einer göttlichen Ansage oder was auch immer. Also man könnte auch sagen, das Subjekt kommt überhaupt erst in Geltung dadurch, dass man seine Rationalität jetzt wirklich wahrnimmt und ernst nimmt und nicht die ganze Zeit, na, du bist ja auch ein Mensch, dann haben wir dieselbe Vernunft, ja, das okkupiert.
Deshalb, Habermas, also du hast es jetzt gerade genannt, dann ja in den letzten Jahren oder in den späten Jahren, vielmehr nicht die letzten, aber die späten Jahre waren es, mit Ratzinger im Austausch ist, weil vielleicht doch noch mal eine andere Grundlage her müsste, so etwas wie die Religion. Nicht, dass er das jetzt ganz affirmativ beantwortet, aber dass er sich überhaupt diese Frage dann stellt und sie sehr gewissenhaft verhandelt, zeigt das ja.
Genau und Religion ist ja nur eingetauschter Begriff für eine verlorene Vernunft. Man kommt also wieder mit einem höheren Gut und ordnet die Menschen da einfach drunter, weshalb ich ja meine finale Empfehlung hier einfach direkt an dich geben kann. Wie wäre es denn, wenn wir das, was ich jetzt als Rationalität, man könnte ja auch Moral sagen, wirklich wieder dem Subjekt unterschiebt? Und die Literaturempfehlung dafür ist natürlich die Moral der Gesellschaft. Klingt wie aus dem großen Kanon von Luhmann, ist es auch, aber nicht eine der Monographien zur Gesellschaft der Gesellschaft, sondern eben ein Sammelband, in dem es aber einen Text gibt, den ich jedem empfehle, die Soziologie der Moral. Also das schon dicke Buch, aber hat einen Text, der über mehr als 100 Seiten geht, in dem man nachlesen kann, wie Luhmann, anders als Habermas, der ja wie Chomsky hier die Vernunft als, ist bei der Geburt schon einprogrammiert, muss nur entfaltet werden. Und da sagt der Luhmann, ne, ne, wir drehen das mal anders rum. Das Subjekt, sage ich jetzt mal ein bisschen vulgär systemtheoretisch, stellen wir den Mittelpunkt. Und man begegnet sich, wenn man kommuniziert und muss Achtungsbedingungen aushandeln. Unterschieden von Respekt und so weiter. Also jeder kann jemanden anhimmeln, jemanden bewundern, wie auch immer. Aber wir kennen ja dann alle die Stories. Irgendwer trifft einen Superstar, dich zum Beispiel, und stellt dann fest, ist ja auch im echten Leben richtig nett. Also jenseits der Bewunderung auf der Bühne, jenseits der Mühe, ist eine Augenhöhe gegeben. Und die ist aber nicht selbstverständlich und die muss eben erarbeitet werden. So, und aus diesen Achtungsbedingungen kann man allgemeine Moral ableiten, dann eine Reflexions-Ebene drüber legen. Das ist dann die Ethik, das Gespräch über die Moral. Aber sie erwächst eben von unten aus den, sagen wir mal aufsummierten Achtungsbedingungen, weshalb Leute auch so einen großen Kulturschock erleben, wenn sie woanders sind. Es trifft da nicht die eigene Sehgewohnheit, dass man irgendwo die Verkehrsregeln anders beachtet. Aber da würde man ja nicht hingehen und sagen, die haben ja alle keine Vernunft. Das ist ja auch in der Zeit, als man sagte, das sind alles Barbaren, ich verstehe gar nicht, welche Sprache die reden, das sind keine Menschen offenbar. So, nein, die bringen einfach eine eigene Ratio in der Tät mit. Also dieser Vernunftbegriff, dieses ganze Habermaschen, die Ideale hier, die ist debil, liberative da, alles muss durchgequasselt werden. Wir lesen einfach alle die Moral der Gesellschaft, also die Soziologie der Moral. Da kann man es lesen. Und als ich vorhin nachschaute, fand ich es superwitzig, der drauffolgende Text dann in dem Band heißt, und das ist superwichtig, also allein der Titel ja, eröffnet schon große Denkgebäude, die Ehrlichkeit der Politiker und die höhere Amoralität der Politik. Solche Texte wollen wir lesen.
Das ist auch die perfekte Überleitung, denn wir gehen jetzt zu einem ernsten Thema, zum Krieg im Iran. Ich habe mir verschiedene Protagonisten dazu angehört, denn mir geht es darum, jetzt zu zeigen, wie wird gerade sehr rechts darüber gesprochen. Wir werden uns erst ein bisschen was aus den USA anhören, gehen dann nach Deutschland über, werden etwas kontrastieren, nämlich ein Auftritt von Joachim Gauck mit einem Auftritt von Tino Chrupalla. Wir werden da erschrocken sein, wie häufig eigentlich Chrupalla zuzustimmen ist und wie verschoben der Diskurs ist durch Joachim Gauck. Und meine These ist, dass die AfD sollte dieser Krieg lange weitergehen und sollte eher entsprechende Folgen haben, die wir ja jetzt schon merken können, dass die AfD nochmal ordentlich Anlauf nehmen könnte, wenn der Diskurs in der Mitte so bleibt oder sich vielleicht sogar in diese Richtung verschärft. Wir gehen aber jetzt erstmal wirklich zum absoluten Abgrund, in den Abgrund hinein. Nämlich wir hören uns jetzt diesen Neonazi, ich glaube anders kann man ihn nicht bezeichnen, Nick Fuentes an, also aus der Rechten in den USA, ein extremer Antisemit, der jetzt aber Folgendes macht. Er regt sich natürlich darüber auf, dass die USA mit Israel zusammen diesen Krieg führen, weil er ohnehin auch Israel hasst. Aber interessant ist, was jetzt passiert. Wir hören uns jetzt einen Auszug aus dem Secular Talk. Das ist ein YouTube-Kanal von einem liberaldemokratischen Typen, der jetzt selbstes kaum fassen kann, wie Nick Fuentes, also dieser Neonazi, plötzlich über Joe Biden spricht, aus einer Enttäuschung über Trump heraus.
Okay, Leute, ihr wisst, dass die Trump-Regime mit dem Trump-Regime kämpfen, weil ihr jetzt die weißen Nationalisten, weißen Supremisten und Nazis für Joe Biden weinen. Sie sind für Sleepy Joe nostalgisch.
Lass uns jetzt eine Liste von Fuentes hören.
Weißt du, wer in der Art und Weise von all dem stand?
Ein Fakt. Ein Fakt.
Joe Biden.
Weil Joe Biden nicht die Bete genommen hat.
Er hat nicht Israels Bete genommen und Iran gefeiert. Als Israel den Iran in April 2024 provokierte und in Juli 2024 Joe Biden Iran zerstört, aber sie nicht attackierte.
Okay, ich sage, er bläst Sleepy Joe hier ein bisschen zu hart.
Was er nicht machen kann, Nick Fuentes ist Rassist. Er kann natürlich nicht Obama loben, den er eigentlich loben müsste, Weil der ja tatsächlich sehr viel zur Befriedung beigetragen hat und was dann wieder so zerfetzt wurde. Nick Fuentes noch weiter. Und wenn Joe Biden da war, hat er das erste, was er versucht hat, eine nukleare Behandlung mit Iran zu rekonstituten. Das war das erste, was er versucht hat.
Was hat in August 2023 passiert?
Nur zwei Monate vor dem 7.
Oktober hat Joe Biden eine Zufriedener-Ausgabe mit Iran gemacht und 6 Billionen Dollar in Assetten entfroren, die in eine South-Korea-Bank verbunden waren.
Ja, das war das Geld.
Nick Fuentes, wer hat von dem schon gehört? Okay, schon sehr viele. Ja, also das ist ein popkulturelles Phänomen. Anders kann man das gar nicht beschreiben, jetzt da geworden, weil der, der das Internet flutet mit diesen endlosen Streams, in denen er seine Propaganda verteilt, jetzt diese Trump-Kritik äußert. Aber wir merken schon, in welche Richtung das geht. Ich habe das jetzt nicht mitgebracht, wo er das noch länger ausführt. Für ihn ist also die Sache klar. Israel ist die eigentliche dämonische Kraft in dem Ganzen. Und wie konnte das nur passieren, dass Trump das mit sich machen lässt? Also der versucht natürlich jetzt, diese Konstruktion zu machen, dass Israel an allem schuld ist oder bluten, würde er glaube ich gerne eigentlich sagen. Wir hören jetzt aus dem Magalager, aus dem zurückgetretenen Magalager, Marjorie Taylor Greene. Die war bei CNN zu Gast. Und da klingt das sehr ähnlich.
Das Krieg ist nicht etwas, das die Amerikaner in 2024 gewählt haben. Wir haben als Bezüglichkeit das Gegenteil gewählt. Wir haben keine weiteren Außenwars, keine mehr Regime verändert. Und wir wurden von vielen Mitgliedern der Administration während der Kampagne, JD. Vance, Tulsi Gabbard und anderen, dass sie glaubten, dass die Krieg mit Iran eine schreckliche Idee wäre. Es war etwas, was Charlie Kirk selbst wieder und wieder gesagt hat. Und Donald Trump, Präsident Trump, ich habe ihn drei Mal gewählt, habe für ihn gewählt, Präsident zu werden, und ich will ihn noch erfolgreich sein. Aber er hat die Amerikaner für über zehn Jahre und noch länger gesagt, dass er glaubt, dass die Außenwars und Regime-Change wirklich eine schlechte Richtung für die Amerikaner sind.
Die Gefahr kommt also von außen her. Dass Trump selbst Kriegslüstern sein könnte, wird völlig ausgeblendet. Sondern es wird nur so gesehen, dass diese Gefahr von außen ist. Die unterminieren uns. Die ist ja auch schon mehrmals auffällig geworden mit der Verbreitung von Verschwörungstheorien. Und für sie ist die Sache also völlig klar. Um das zugespitzt zu sagen, was Trump jetzt gerade noch davor schützt, dass die den wirklich absägen, ist deren Antisemitismus. Weil sie so sich immer noch rechtfertigen, Israel steckt hinter allem, die Juden sind eigentlich schuld, die sind auch hier in unserer Regierung überall. Und eigentlich will Trump immer noch das Beste für uns. Und es wird am allerdeutlichsten jetzt bei dem Nationalberater für Terrorismusbekämpfung, der jetzt zurückgetreten ist, Joe Kent, der dann sofort zu Tucker Carlson geht, bei dem man auch schon munkelt, könnte er möglicherweise kandidieren als nächster Präsident. Und der ja auch nun durch die Verbreitung von antisemitischen Verschwörungstheorien auffällig geworden ist. Dort sagt Joe Kent jetzt Folgendes.
Die Krieg mit Iran ist vielleicht das Ende von viel für die USA.
An diesem Punkt fühlt es sich so, dass es keinen Weg mehr gibt.
Was ist die Antwort?
Es wird eine drastische Aktion nehmen. Die gute Nachricht ist, dass das etwas ist, was Präsident Trump einzigartig qualifiziert ist, und das ist die Hauptproblematik, was die Israelis tun.
Joe Kent hat ein Statement veröffentlicht, dass er das nicht mehr mitmachen kann und deshalb zurücktritt von seinem Amt, weil er diesen Krieg auf den Iran verurteilt. Man denkt jetzt, der hat sich also mit Trump völlig verkracht. Er sagt jetzt gerade, Trump ist Gott sei Dank jemand, der in so einer Lage gut reagieren kann.
Wir sind sehr geflüchtet, und wahrscheinlich mit einem neuen Team von Diplomaten gehen die Israelis und sagen, du bist fertig, wir werden dich befriedigen. Aber du bist fertig mit der Offensivität.
Das ist unsere Krieg, wir bezahlen für sie, wir weinen für sie.
Wenn du diese offensivige Operation weiterführen willst, werden wir die Features deiner Offensivsysteme ausdrehen, damit du auf deiner eigenen Seite bist. Wir müssen das ihnen sagen. Und ich weiß, dass viele Leute, die die Israelis lieben, sagen, das ist falsch, sie sind unter dem Feuer.
Ja, hier muss ich kurz anmerken, wir hätten eigentlich ein Bild von dem Clip gehabt, den habe ich irgendwie beim Ummodeln, Klamotten wie auch immer, aber es gab ja gestern dieses Foto von ihm, das ja überall auch in den deutschen Medien gezeigt wurde, dass er jetzt da zurück tritt und so. Was hier super auffällig ist, Schon bei Nick Fuentes, das sind halt Leute, die führen einfach einen politischen Diskurs ganz streng an Inhalten. Wir mögen halt die Inhalte nicht, deswegen sind wir da mal abgelenkt, aber die verschwenden überhaupt keine Zeit damit, sich einen Freiraum für ihren nächsten Satz zu erkämpfen, sondern die schießen sofort los.
Wenn ich da mal einhaken darf, nein, das ist gut, da lässt ja.
Richtig knallhart reingeschossen. Was bedeutet für normale Zuschauer und ich bin ja auch ein normaler Fernsehzuschauer, findet halt nur dort politischer Diskurs statt. Ja, bei den anderen nicht.
Das andere ist geredet.
Genau, die anderen reden einfach nur. Und wenn man sich einmischen will, und diesen Text hatten wir ja mal, dass in der Fläche Amerika, dass die Kommunalpolitik bestimmt wird von Republikanern. Ja. Und wenn jemand ein Anliegen hat, spielt es gar keine Rolle mehr, dass man das auch nicht, es gibt ja gar keine Demokraten, bei denen man sich engagieren kann, sondern man muss das dann bei den Republikanern machen. Und hier sieht man es, wie das auch von oben genauso drückt. Die Leute wollen auf YouTube Inhalte sehen. Und wenn Major Taylor Greene da erzählt, das war ja bisher ihr Beitrag, da kommen die Juden mit Lasern aus dem Weltraum und schießen auf unsere Kinder oder sowas. So ist sie ins Amt gekommen oder ins Mandat. Dann hören die Leute dazu, weil da einfach direkt auf den Punkt geredet wird.
Um nicht missverstanden zu werden, natürlich hat die israelische Regierung ein großes Interesse daran, dass dieser Krieg stattfindet. Netanyahu will seit 30 Jahren eigentlich diesen Krieg. Das will ich hier gar nicht in Abrede stellen. Nur, was daraus jetzt gemacht wurde, ist, dass die eine Welt konstruieren, in der Israel Weltherrscher ist und USA unterminiert werden und deshalb keine eigene Selbstständigkeit mehr haben. Donald Trump wurde jetzt offenbar auch von denen gefangen genommen. Sie sind quasi jetzt hier und versuchen den Befreiungsschlag von den Israelis. Also das ist die antisemitische Erzählung, die haben. Natürlich gibt es hier ja offenbar eindeutig ein Interesse zwischen Netanyahu und Trump, wie immer das dann genau verläuft, den Iran anzugreifen, was man auch getan hat. Dann war ich doch noch mal kurz bei Twitter, habe irgendwas gepostet und sah einen Tweet von Paul Ronzheimer, der lobte eine Sendung von Karen Mioska, in der Joachim Gauck zu Gast war. Da könne man wieder sehen, was für ein großartiger Bundespräsident er war und dass so ein Steinmeier da niemals heranreichen kann. Dann schrieb er über diesen Tweet noch einen Tweet und sagte, schade, dass Gauck nicht alleine in der Sendung sitzen konnte und eine ganze Stunde reden durfte, sondern dass dann im zweiten Teil des Gesprächs noch andere Gäste dabei waren. Ja, das ist natürlich unglaublich, dass wir nicht unseren Präsidenten alleine bekommen, sondern noch jemand anderes dabei ist. Aber wir, kann ich versprechen, hören jetzt gleich nur unseren Altbundespräsidenten und nicht diese anderen Leute, die da dabei sitzen. Miosga spricht mit ihm nämlich in den ersten zehn Minuten über den Iran.
Ein Iraner hat zu mir gesagt, wenn wir weiter unter diesem Tyrannen leben, dann ist das ein Sterben auf Raten, das deutlich mehr Opfer fördern wird, als durch die Bomben, die jetzt auf Iran nieder passen. Können Sie das verstehen?
Ja, das kann ich gut verstehen. Ich kann überhaupt verstehen, dass es Sinn macht, Diktatoren zu beseitigen. Nur muss man sich, und die Amerikaner haben jetzt Erfahrungen. Wir wissen, wie es war im Irak und wir wissen, wir wissen, wie es ausschaut in Libyen, wenn man sich zum Regime-Change entschließt.
Ich verstehe es noch nicht so ganz.
Muss man durchziehen oder was soll man sagen?
Wir müssen es jetzt versuchen zu verstehen. Also es ist mindestens so kompliziert wie ein Text von Jürgen Habermas, würde ich sagen. Aber nicht, weil es so abstrakt und intelligent ist, sondern ich würde sagen, es ist ein bisschen wirr. Aber es muss so wirr sein, damit man am Ende da rauskommt, wo er rauskommt. Also wir hören schon in Jahren, man kann das also verstehen, dass es jetzt diesen Angriff gibt. Die Amerikaner haben Erfahrung, aber eigentlich wollte er damit ja sagen, na ja, weil sie wissen auch, wie schlecht das ausgehen kann, zum Beispiel im Irak.
Aber legitimiert Herr Gauck, dieses Leid, einen Krieg, den Israel und Amerika jetzt gegen Iran führen, der seit zwei Wochen...
Da sind sich nun die Juristen ja uneinig. Es gibt Völkerrechtler, die sagen, das kann man machen, weil man ein schlimmes Übel beseitigen will.
Ich habe die Völkerrechtler jetzt nicht so gehört. Diese Völkerrechtler, die da die ganze Zeit sagen, das kann man auf jeden Fall machen.
Also wir bekommen ja auch weniger aus dem Völkerrecht als aus dem Kuhstein. Ja, aber wir können glaube ich sagen... Bei dem Völkerrecht ist zumindest das relativ klar definiert. Entweder das Land ist eine konkrete Bedrohung für dich oder aus dem Land selbst wirst du um Hilfe gebeten.
Ja.
Ansonsten ist Grenzüberschritt tabu.
Das heißt, wir müssten vielleicht das Völkerrecht kritisch sehen.
Das heißt, es gibt immer die Überlegung, wen schützt das Völkerrecht jetzt? Und das Völkerrecht schützt nicht legitimierte Macht in einem Staat, genauso wie legitimierte Macht. Das heißt, das Völkerrecht macht keinen Unterschied, ob das eine Diktatur ist oder nicht. Die Menschen wünschen sich natürlich, sie möchten Anteil haben an dem, was die Vereinten Nationen beschlossen haben, an Rechten der Menschen, am Recht, Rechte zu haben.
Das heißt dann für Gauck folgendes.
Und deshalb ist ein Angriff in so einer Situation, wo das Völkerrecht kritisch sagen würde, das geht nicht. Das kann ich nachvollziehen. Auf der anderen Seite sind da diese Abermillionen von Menschen, die gerne möchten, dass sie befreit werden von ihren Unterdrückern. Und da stehen nun zwei Rechtsgüter gegeneinander, das Völkerrecht und die individuellen Rechte der einzelnen Menschen, die unterdrückt sind.
Bedeutet hier, dass Netanyahu und Trump für diese individuellen Rechte jetzt gerade da kämpfen und diesen Angriff machen. Und das ist zwar strittig zum Völkerrecht, aber dann hat man damit diesen Freiheitsimpuls genüge getan.
Ja, ich habe auch heute Morgen dieses Video rum aus mehreren Richtungen gefilmt, bin mittlerweile sehr wirklich überall in der Kamera, wie dieses 15-stöckige Haus in Beirut unten attackiert wird von einer israelischen Rakete und wirklich umfällt, als hätten da drei Monate lang Sprengmeister irgendwie dran rumgefuhrwärkt und so. Und das jetzt zu verknüpfen mit so, müsste man jetzt fragen, sieht das dann aus, wenn die individuellen Rechte verteidigt werden? Weil die lassen sich ja über diesen Weg von außen nur so verteidigen. Also ja, man meint jetzt nicht, dass da Leute hingehen, um dann Leute an die Hand zu nehmen, um gegen den Staat Rechte durchzudrücken oder so, sondern dieses.
Über diese Maßnahmen könnte man ja nachdenken. Also wie unterstützt man die Iraner, die auf den Straßen versucht haben, zu demonstrieren und niedergemetzelt wurden und so weiter?
Ja, nur da steckt ja die Pointe drin, dass man mittlerweile ja die, also Amerika nach akademischen Gesichtspunkten selber nicht mehr als Demokratie bewertet. Was ja dann auch wieder dieses Pointe unterstützt, dass Trump vielleicht auch gezögert hat, zur Höhe, also als intensiv in Iran Proteste waren, weil in Minneapolis quasi dieselben Proteste waren. Und man auf der einen Seite im Inland sich gegen die Proteste wendet, oben dann im Ausland, wie Gauck sagen würde, mithilfe von militärischem Material individuelle Rechtsdurchsetzungen zu liefern. Und das ist ja, das geht ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Dabei werden wir auch noch erfahren, dass die USA ja auch schlimm sind, interessanterweise. Aber jetzt erst noch mal spielt Karin Mioska einen Ausschnitt von Friedrich Merz Gauck vor.
Und selbst umfangreiche Sanktionspakete haben über Jahre und Jahrzehnte wenig ausgerichtet. Das hat auch daran gelegen, dass wir nicht bereit waren, grundlegende Interessen notfalls mit militärischer Gewalt durchzusetzen.
Habe ich auch nicht ganz verstanden. Also, dass die Sanktionen nicht so wirksam sind. Das kann man alles in Büchern nachlesen. Das ist bekannt, dass hier mehr Sanktionen kommen, irgendwann, die nicht mehr eine Wirksamkeit entfalten. Niklas Mulder hat das Buch dazu geschrieben, dass er jetzt sagt, wir waren nicht bereit, das mit militärischen Mitteln durchzusetzen. Hätte man jetzt zu Merkel-Ära einen Angriff auf den Iran fliegen müssen? Oder was soll das sein? Nein, ich frage mich wirklich, was er damit meinte. Joschka will dann von Gauck wissen, wie er das einschätzt.
Also in diesem Sinne, das Völkerrecht kann in die Mottenkiste?
Nein, das wollen wir natürlich nicht hoffen, dass es so weit kommt. Wir sehen jetzt, dass bedeutende Player in der Welt auf das Völkerrecht verzichten, weil sie sich lieber auf ihre militärische Macht stützen. Das tut China, das tut Russland ganz besonders mit seinem widerwärtigen Angriffskrieg gegenüber der Ukraine. Und das tun andere Akteure auch.
Welche?
Das wird nicht gesagt.
China, Russland und andere Akteure.
Ja. Aber?
Aber dass ein langjähriger Hüter des Rechtes, nämlich die Vereinigten Staaten, jetzt im Grunde auch zurückfällt in diese Gedankenwelt derer, die nicht die Stärke des Rechtes, sondern die militärische Stärke für das eigentliche Elementare im politischen Raum halten. Das ist ja das Bedrückende, dass im Grunde das Völkerrecht seinen stärksten Hüter verloren hat.
Das passiert, wenn man Sprechakte mit realer Politik verwechselt und bei Amerika immer nur die State of the Union hört.
Ja, ich frage mich jetzt auch gerade, setze jetzt doch zu einem Plädoyer für das Völkerrecht an und sagt, auf keinen Fall stoppt diesen Angriffskrieg. Frage ich mich, aber er macht erst einmal einen Schlenker.
Koreaner, Japaner, Australier, also wir haben ja auch Verbündete around the world, die das Völkerrecht achten. Das sind aber zum Teil Mittelmächte. Und diese Mittelmächte haben ihre Macht noch nicht erkannt. Und der Premier Carney von von Kanada hat uns Europäer kürzlich in München erinnert. Also wir sollen nicht nur auf unsere Werte setzen, sondern sollen uns selber ertüchtigen.
Ja, er hat das in Davos gesagt und auch nicht so ganz genau, aber lassen wir das mal so stehen. Jetzt möchte es Mioska doch mal genauer wissen.
Wie ist Ihre Position, Herr Gauck? Verurteilen Sie also den völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg der Amerikaner und der Israelis?
Verstehe ich das so?
Nein, so eindeutig ist es nicht. Und ich kann es nicht. Es geht ein Riss praktisch durch mich selber. Ich sehe die Not dieser leidenden Menschen, die über Jahrzehnte unterdrückt sind und wo ganz besonders weibliche Menschen eine ganz besonders miese Rolle spielen. Und ich sehe den Mut dieser Menschen. Ich sehe die Verletzung der Rechte der Menschen. Und ich möchte, dass das sich ändert. Und wenn ich aus dieser Perspektive schaue, dann finde ich es angemessen, dass man von außen ihnen hilft.
Also das ist die Hilfe, die man anbietet von Trump. Trump bietet die Hilfe an.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Glauben Sie denn, dass es den Amerikanern darum geht?
Das ist eine andere Geschichte. Aber denen da drin geht es da darum.
Wie kann das sein? Und jetzt, wie will ich schon mal vorbereiten, weil jetzt gleich die Tino Chrupalla-Clips kommen. Man muss sich einfach den nicht besonders politischen, aber so halbwegs noch interessierten Zuschauer vorstellen, der sich diese Sendung ansieht. Und sagt, ja, ist der Bundespräsident, Mioska ist eine wichtige Sendung, Iran interessiert mich, was ist denn da los? Ich merke es ja auch schon im eigenen Portemonnaie. Ich höre da mal zu. Wenn Gauck immer überall rumtourt und sagt, wie können wir die Demokratie retten, dann würde ich sagen, genau so kann man die Demokratie beenden, weil die, die da vorsitzen und wenn sie nur zwei klare Gedanken fassen können, denken, okay, hier ist jetzt aber wirklich die Reißleine zu ziehen. Das hat keinen Zweck mit diesem Mann und auch offenbar keinen Zweck, im Diskurs noch irgendwie mitzumischen, wenn so geredet wird. Das heißt, das ist wirklich das abschreckende Beispiel und für mich sehr symptomatisch. Gauck will jetzt was also?
Und ich habe ja gerade gesagt, dass ich von ihrer Seite aus gucke. Und deshalb ist meine Kritik eine gebremste Kritik. Ich sehe, wohin wir geraten, wenn wir das Völkerrecht völlig preisgeben. Wir leben aber in einer Zeit, wo das Völkerrecht den Schutz des Lebens vieler nicht mehr garantiert.
Das heißt, wir nehmen das Völkerrecht dann, wenn es uns passt. Das ist die Antwort. Dann muss man das so sagen, aber dann kann man nicht so rumlovieren. Wenn wir uns jetzt vorstellen, diese Zuschauer, die da alle jetzt saßen und haben sich das angesehen und sagen, was ist denn da jetzt los? Also, wie kann man denen ja auch nicht mehr zuhören? Zwei Tage später gucken die Markus Lanz. Und dann sitzt da Tino Chrupalla. So, und das sind Leute, meine ich jetzt, die gucken dazu, die jetzt noch nicht die Affinität eigentlich so stark haben, dass sie die AfD wählen würden. Aber die sagen also, was gefällt mir jetzt gerade gar nicht mit dem Iran? Und der Kanzler laviert da so rum und selbst der Bundespräsident, der ehemalige, weiß dann nicht klar zu sagen, was ist denn nun jetzt da? Und jetzt hört man Tino Chrupalla.
Der Angriff, die Tötung Jameneys. Wo stehen sie da? War das richtig?
Also ich halte das für schwierig, wenn man einen Staatsoberhaupt, egal ob man ihn gut oder schlecht findet, und sicherlich ist Jameney sicherlich kein Staatsoberhaupt, was für sein Volk Gutes bewirkt hat. Das will ich ganz klar sagen. Und nichtsdestotrotz ist es, denke ich, selten oder einzigartig, dass man einen Staatsoberhaupt haut, auf diese Art und Weise tötet, ausschaltet. Die Frage ist, was bezweckt man damit und was erreicht man damit?
Fängt also jetzt erst mal auch so an, denkt man, wird das auch so eine Gauck-Antwort, wird aber anders dann.
Und ich sehe bei diesem ganzen völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg, das ist es, keine Exit-Strategie, überhaupt keine Strategie, was man eigentlich bezwecken will. Will man einen Regime-Chance erzeugen? Das sehe ich einfach nicht. Und das können ja die Amerikaner und die Israelis selbst nicht sagen. Und teilweise widersprechen sie sich ja auch.
Hier muss man aber, glaube ich, kurz anmerken, bei Lanz ist ja Chrupalla sehr beliebt, sehr häufig zu Gast. Und die Alice Weidel wird das ja als Zuschauerin gerade sehen, sich hier einen eigenen Teil dazu denken. Also hier laufen auch die inner AfD-Kämpfe.
Werden wir gleich ein bisschen erleben, die Binnendiskurse innerhalb der AfD. Hier versucht tatsächlich jemand zu sagen, ich bin, wenn ihr wollt, euer nächster Kanzler.
Sie kritisieren das, sie berufen sich aufs Völkerrecht. Welches Vorgehen hätten Sie sich gewünscht?
Ich denke, das ist ja auch unsere Position als AfD, im Übrigen auch in unserem Parteiprogramm, dass wir Regime Change ablehnen. Und dass natürlich diese Umbildung auch von Regierungen muss vom iranischen Volk selbst kommen, aus dem iranischen Volk im eigenen Land. Man wird ein Land. Und das hat gerade der Nahe Osten gezeigt, mit den vielen Kriegen und Konflikten, Irak, Libyen, Syrien, Afghanistan auch, dass man solche Regime-Change mit Bombardements nicht bewegen wird, dort eine andere Politik zu machen.
Bislang gab es ja auch noch keinen Regime-Change, der allein mit Bombardements stattgefunden hat. Lanz kommt jetzt mit einem Zitat.
Würden Sie folgenden Satz unterschreiben? Ich fordere die Vereinigten Staaten Israel und den Iran auf, die Lage zu deeskalieren, die Nachbarländer nicht in diesen Konflikt reinzuziehen und zu Diplomatie und Verhandlungen zurückzukehren.
Absolut.
Wissen Sie, von wem der ist?
Sagen Sie es mir, von den Linken. Von Frau Baerbock hat sie ja mal einen Treffer gemacht. Ist ja auch mal was wert.
Annalena Baerbock.
Ja, schön, sie lernt also.
Naja, das war immer ihre Position. Aber Sie sind offenbar so nah an sie herangerückt.
Sehr gut.
Das kann man natürlich so machen, aber das Publikum versteht es schon so, wie es gemeint ist. Ja, ich bin jetzt hier auf der Seite des Arguments. Also das bessere Argument ist das Argument, dem ich zustimme. Wir könnten jetzt fast schon wieder zu Habermas übergehen. Und das muss man sich vorstellen, wie das wirkt bei all denen, die diese Sendung sich ansehen. So muss man das ja jetzt gerade immer sehen. Was bedeutet das? Lanz?
Wenn Sie sagen unsere, wen meinen Sie dann? Meinen Sie dann Ihre Position oder meinen Sie beispielsweise die Position von Rainer Kraft auch Mitglied Ihrer Partei, der sagt, wenn rechte Patrioten sich genauso anhören wie Annalena Baerbock, dann ist die Chance groß, dass es sich gar nicht um rechte Patrioten handelt.
Ja, es sind Einzelmeinungen, die es in jeder Partei auch gibt.
Aber sind Sie ein rechter Patriot?
Ich bin natürlich ein Patriot. Keine Frage.
Ein rechter Patriot.
Von mir aus auch gerne ein rechter Patriot.
Immer ein eigener Mann stellt das in Abrede, richtig?
Ja, wenn er das in Abrede stellt, nochmal unsere Position der Bundestagsfraktion und auch des AK Außen. Das ist da deutlich. Auch die Verurteilung Raminez und auch des Regimes.
Der ist Mitglied des Bundestages.
Ja, er ist nicht Mitglied zum Beispiel des AK Außen. Er ist auch kein Außenpolitiker.
RGC sowas?
Das ist seine persönliche Meinung.
Wir erleben jetzt, dass die AfD sich in dieser Frage spaltet. Ob das jetzt zu einem riesengroßen Krach kommt, wird die Frage sein dann, wenn dieser Krieg noch lange andauert und große wirtschaftliche Schäden verursacht in Deutschland. Momentan ist ja davon auszugehen, dass das noch lange weitergehen wird. Und möglicherweise ist das, was wir mit der Energiekrise bei Russlands Angriffe auf die Ukraine erlebt haben, dann ein Kindergarten gewesen, was da noch eigentlich uns drohen kann. Man weiß, wie sehr die AfD das für sich nutzen konnte. Jetzt hat sie hier diese Klarheit in der Position, damit haben wir nichts zu tun. Aber die wird vertreten von Chrupalla. Die wird nicht vertreten von allen in der AfD. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie sich das verteilt, aber ich würde sagen, es ist vielleicht gerade so eine Position, 60 Prozent Chrupalla, 40 Prozent bleiben bei so einem transatlantischen Modell kleben.
Wir haben zuletzt im Fernsehpodcast mit Florettine, unsere Abgeordnete, die im Vorrufing-Stream hat, und Mick, zwei super interessante Beobachtungen gemacht. Zum einen wird aber nicht so viel diskutiert, aber ein paar Clips gab es dann doch, heutzutage ein Tagesthema. Was ist eigentlich das Regime und kann man es changen in Irak? Wir reden ja immer von dieser ideologischen Führung, die dann irgendwie so eiertollermäßig, halbsakral, wie auch immer. Und da muss halt so ein geistiger Führer gesucht werden. Nur im Griff ist ja das Land von diesem Revolutionsgarten. Das ist also für sich eine Organisation, die so groß ist, dass sie einfach der halbe Staat ist. Da leben 90 Millionen Menschen und das halbe Wirtschaftsleben, also wirklich die Hälfte des kompletten wirtschaftlichen Eigentums gehört in Revolutionsgarten.
Ja, das ist der Staat als Beute tatsächlich.
Genau. Wir sind also kurz vor chinesischen Verhältnissen. Alles gehört der Partei. So und die haben natürlich bis auf jeden Straßenzug, also jeden zweiten Kiosk, jeden zweiten Handwerksbetrieb, jede zweite Fabrik einfach gar nicht eine Ideologie durchgestrickt, sondern einfach eine Profitlogik. Und die kann man niemanden aus der Hand schlagen. Also dass Leute auf die Straße gehen, um dort wirklich einen Massenmord an Zehntausenden zu verüben, um ihre eigenen Freunde da abzusichern. Das ist die Realität dort. Also das kann man mit Luft kriegt schon mal gar nicht. Das Land ist 1700 mal 1900 Kilometer. Also wer soll da einmarschieren und jeden Straßenzug von den Revolutionsgarten zurück eroben?
Das ist mehr als viermal so groß wie Deutschland.
Genau. Und das dann im Kontrast. Und das ist diese zweite Sache, die hier jetzt super wichtig ist. Also da ist eigentlich gar nichts zu machen, erst recht nicht mit den Mitteln, die wir gerade sehen. Und angewendet werden die Mitteln aber von Amerika und Israel. Jetzt hat ja die AfD diesen großen Pivot gemacht, zu sagen, eigentlich ist ja diese Trump-Partei unser Freund. Sie sind nur leider Amerikaner, aber hoffentlich lernen die Deutschen schnell genug, dass der Trump ziemlich cool ist, obwohl er Amerikaner ist, weil die Zustimmungswerte, was heißt Zustimmungswerte, also es gab eben Politbarometer beim ZDF, eine Umfrage. Die Frage lautete, vertrauen sie, und dann wurde ein Land genannt. Man weiß also gar nicht genau, was diese Frage bedeutet. Aber bei Frankreich sagten die Deutschen zu 83 Prozent, ja, ich vertraue Frankreich, was auch immer das bedeutet. Also das ist sozusagen jetzt eingepreist. Bei Israel war der Wert 17 Prozent, nur unterboten von Amerika 15 Prozent. Also Chrupalla sieht hier sicher auch gerade in einem Aufwind einer deutschen Bevölkerung im Rücken. Er kann gerade beide richtig eins auswischen. Also hier ist wirklich gerade Highlife.
Und so muss man das auch sehen. Und wenn jetzt aus der Regierung, also aus SPD und CDU, nicht solche Töne auch angeschlagen werden, dann weiß man, dass das alles immer Punkt-Siege für die AfD sind. Das wird auch sich zuspitzen. Die Frage ist dann, ist das im Ganzen dann für die Parteien eine Stärkung oder werden die sich gegenseitig so sehr anfeinden, dass das innerhalb der Strukturen zerbricht? Denn was wir ja jetzt schon sehen können, ist, es gibt ja eigentlich zwei Fraktionen, wenn man so sagen will. Die einen wollen ja ein bürgerliches Lager haben, ein neues bürgerliches Lager mit der CDU zusammen. Also man will quasi blau, schwarz oder schwarz-blau haben. Dazu gehören übrigens ja auch Leute wie Gauland, auch die AfD-Leute, die oft bei Nios zu Gast sind, die wollen das. Wir werden auch gleich noch kurz was von Nios hören. Das drohe ich schon mal an. Und die andere Seite, leider nicht von Valdir Hartmann. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der da mit Iran und so, das ist ja auch alles so weit weg.
Doch, er kann auch noch mal sagen, es muss ja so kommen.
Ja, so kommen.
Und die andere Seite ist die, die sagt, nein, nein, wir müssen ja die CDU nach wie vor zerstören. Wir brauchen einfach eine richtige, rechte, starke Partei in Deutschland. Und dann muss auf Unabhängigkeit, Souveränität gerade auch in den internationalen Beziehungen gepocht werden. Und gerade das kann jetzt ein Tino Chrupalla sehr stark machen, weil es nicht einfach jetzt ein geopolitischer Diskurs ist, der irgendwo auf einem Podium stattfindet, sondern das ist jetzt wirklich Blick zur Zapfsäule, Blick ins Portemonnaie. Die ganze Zeit nur das zu fahren. Das ist das Entscheidende. Und ich meine, wir haben auch diese Katastrophen ja wieder sehenden Auges kommen lassen. Also das war ja doch interessant. Nach Russlands Angriffe auf die Ukraine waren sich alle einig, jetzt dürfen wir uns nicht wieder in solche Abhängigkeiten bewegen. Vorsicht, Vorsicht. Alle haben da getönt. Und wie hat man nur und wie konnte Merkel? All diese Töne. Und dann hatte ich damals im Presseclub gesagt, zwei Monate, drei Monate nach Kriegsbeginn, ja, wir diversifizieren jetzt gerade das Autokratenportfolio, um zu mahnen, na, das könnte ja auch wieder schwierig werden. Und genau das haben wir ja getan, sind nach Katar. Wir wissen, was da jetzt gerade los ist mit dem Gas. Wir haben auf LNG gesetzt, aus den USA. Haben also natürlich da kurz mal eine Brücke bauen müssen. Das ist ja auch zugestanden richtig gewesen. Nur hat man dann ja gesagt, okay, dann warten wir mal ab. Funktioniert ja jetzt alles. Gas-Speicher, Ölspeicher, ist ja alles wieder da. Man hätte jetzt ja durchaus mehr als vier Jahre Zeit gehabt, radikal in Erneuerbare zu setzen. Nicht, dass wir damit jetzt vollkommen aus dem Schneider werden, aber man hätte sich viel unabhängiger machen können. Was machen wir im Gegenteil? Also die kleinen Schritte, die Habeck ja dann machen konnte oder machen durfte, die werden ja jetzt noch abgebaut.
Na ja, Habeck, Habeck, wer war der Redelsführer dieser Ideen? Wer stand im Bundestag und hat gesagt, die Erneuerbaren sind Friedens- und Freiheitstechnologie?
Ja.
Christian Lindner.
Absurd, also das hier ist jetzt wirklich mal mit Ansage alles passiert. Lanz fragt jetzt noch mal zu diesen Binnenstreitigkeiten in der AfD.
Wenn ihr außenpolitischer Sprecher, das ist jetzt nicht irgendjemand, Markus Frohnmaier sagt, die Trump-Administration hat mit chirurgischer Präzision und klarer Zielorientierung gehandelt. Hat er dann recht?
Na ja, wenn man das jetzt sieht, mit Sicherheit nicht, aber er hat das bezogen auf den Krieg im Irak. Dass es eben dort nicht verzogen wurde und hat gehofft, dass sicherlich mit einem Schlag im Iran das, sage ich mal, möglich ist.
Das bezog sich nicht auf den Irak.
Er hat es aber so begründet. Er wurde ja auch auf diese Aussage, auf der Statement so gefragt. Wenn man natürlich die Bilder sieht, kann man nicht von chirurgischer Genauigkeit sprechen.
Frohnmaier, also der Baden-Württemberg-Kandidat, ist ja sogar zu offiziellen Terminen in der letzten Wahlwoche nicht mehr hingegangen, weil er in den USA war, um die Trump-Administration zu treffen. Das ist also jetzt der totale Antipode, zu dem Chrupalla sich jetzt so, na ja, irgendwie noch moderat kollegial verhält.
War er nicht sogar an Wahlarten selbst bei den Medien?
Nee, da kam er dann doch noch nieder, weil er schon dachte, es ist vielleicht ganz wichtig, da zu sein. Aber dass die am Ende Chrupalla und Alice Weidel in Baden-Württemberg waren, zum Teil, und der Frohnmaier selbst nicht, zeigt natürlich auch was.
Sie haben in dem Zusammenhang gesagt, diese chirurgische Kriegsführung kann man deutlich in Frage stellen, wenn man iranische Mädchenschulen trifft.
So ist es. Oder wenn man Wasser in Salzungsanlagen trifft, das hat dann nichts mehr mit chirurgischer Kriegsführung zu tun.
Sind das Kriegsverbrechen?
Das sind Kriegsverbrechen, natürlich.
Die die Israelis begehen und die die Amerikaner begehen?
Wenn man eine Mädchenschule trifft, ist das ein Kriegsverbrechen, ganz klar.
Wenn man den Salzungsanlagen zerstört?
Wenn man zivile Infrastruktur trifft, auch.
Diese Klarheit, wir müssen uns immer wieder fragen, wie wirkt das beim Publikum zu Hause? Genau in dieser Klarheit. Lanz fragt jetzt zu Gaza.
Dem zusammen Herr Chrupalla, Sie waren einer, der damals auch, ich glaube der Einzige in Ihrer Partei, der Position zu Gaza bezogen hat. Das ist mir damals aufgefallen. Wie sehen Sie das heute?
Ich meine, wenn man die Bilder aus Gaza sieht, dann denke ich, war meine Position auch nicht die Falscheste gewesen.
Nämlich?
Naja, dass auch das, was dort passiert ist, ein Kriegsverbrechen ist. Ich meine, im Gaza wurde ja im Prinzip, wenn man jetzt noch mal zurückkommt, auf chirurgische Kriegsführung. Also ich meine, da steht ja nichts mehr. Da steht ja kein Stein mehr auf dem anderen.
Auch hier, welches Publikum kann da noch mal angesprochen werden? Auch eines, das sogar enttäuscht ist, jetzt vielleicht von Binnenstreitigkeiten bei der Linken, enttäuscht ist von der CDU. Also ich sehe hier wirklich, wie eine Partei noch mal Anlauf nehmen könnte. Und das ist aber dann tatsächlich zuzuschreiben, all den anderen, die nicht klar Dinge benennen. Wir versuchen noch mal kurz, den allgemeinen Diskurs abzubilden. Also damit meine ich nicht den Diskurs in der Öffentlichkeit, sondern in der medialen Öffentlichkeit. Der Weltjournalist Friedrich Schindler ist zu Gast.
Das hängt einer islamistischen Märtyrerideologie an. Das versucht irgendwie diese Vernichtungsfantasien gegen Israel noch irgendwie theologisch zu begründen. Da kommt man nicht mit Diplomatie an gegen ein solches Regime.
Was ist passiert, Herr Schindler?
Eine Schwächung des iranischen Regimes, dieses terroristischen Mullerregimes ist sicherlich für die iranische Bevölkerung gut.
Und dadurch finden sie diese Angriffe und auch die Fortführung dieses Krieges, auch mit dem, was jetzt im Libanon passiert, auch was im Westjordanland passiert, das finden sie alles gut und richtig.
Das habe ich nicht gesagt, wenn sie zum Beispiel die iranischen Mädchenschule ansprechen und es selbstverständlich aufgearbeitet wird.
Aber Sie haben das doch, könnte ich zurückgeben, aber das haben Sie doch auch in keinem Tweet in irgendeiner Weise verurteilt, genau diesen Angriff.
Ich bin kein Politiker, sondern ich bin Journalist, der beobachtet, was...
Aber bei anderen Tweets sind Sie doch auch sehr israelfreundlich. Ich meine, ich verstehe das. Gerade als Springerjournalist muss man das ja ein Stück weit, wenn man den Arbeitsvertrag sieht. Ich habe schon mehrmals die sächsische Regierung kritisiert für bestimmte Kriegsregionen und so weiter. Ich finde, wenn man Freund Israels ist, muss man auch Israel kritisieren dürfen und können. Und das tue ich, gerade in der jetzigen Situation. Und ich finde es nicht richtig, was dort passiert.
Man hat mitunter dann so ein bisschen den Eindruck, das ist von der Welt so ein Argumentationsbord, dass man das so runter raten kann.
Das ist ein Volk, das gegenübersteht einem terroristischen Regime, das 10.000 Demonstranten getötet hat, das immer wieder Oppositionelle einkerkert, foltert, in Gefängnissen und so weiter.
Aber ein Regime-Change hat auch im Nahen Osten, das scheint dann noch nie funktioniert. So wie sie sich das jetzt vorstellen oder wo sie meinen, dass wir damit das iranische Volk in irgendeiner Weise zu einer neuen Regierung verhelfen, in dem wir Bomber und Demons stattfinden lassen. Und wenn ich jetzt höre, teilweise auch Aussagen von israelischen Politikern, die davon sprechen oder auch selbst Donald Trump. Entschuldigung, ich bin zum Anfang seiner Präsidentschaft wirklich von ihm überzeugt gewesen, dass er Kriege beendet, dass er Friedenspräsident. Sie waren ja bei der Amtsanführung dabei.
Sie wurden dazu explizit eingeladen. Das fand ich uns bemerkenswert, Entschuldigung, weil Sie das gerade ansprechen.
Lanz fragt jetzt nach Trump.
Sie haben über ihn gesagt, da sehen wir ihn gerade im Hintergrund, der muss aufpassen, dass er nicht als Kriegspräsident endet.
Ja.
Noch mal der Weltjournalist.
Und dann reden wir nicht mehr von 10.000 Toten, von dahingemetzelten Kindern und Frauen, sondern werden wir von 100.000 oder vielleicht sogar von Millionen reden. Oder von Pflichtlingsströmen, die wir jetzt schon sehen. Wenn ich mir einen Libanon angucke, wo schon bereits 700.000 Menschen auf der Flucht sind.
An vielen Pflichtlingsströmen war ja das iranische Regime mitverantwortlich. Das iranische Regime hat ja das Assad-Regime sehr stark unterstützt, was sehr große Fluchtbewegungen ausgelöst hat nach Europa und auch nach Deutschland. Das iranische Regime unterstützt Terrororganisationen wie die Hamas, wie auch die Hezbollah und die Houthi. Der 7. Oktober, über den wir gerade gesprochen haben, wäre nicht möglich gewesen ohne diese Unterstützung des iranischen Regimes.
Da bin ich dabei hin, dass man Islamismus bekämpfen muss. Aber Islamismus müssen wir als Allererstes in Deutschland bekämpfen und nicht im Iran. Das ist nicht unsere Aufgabe.
Schüttler, versuchst du es jetzt noch mal mit anderen Beispielen?
Aber der Iran unterstützt auch den Islamismus in Deutschland.
Ja, aber wir haben auch gesehen, mit der Machtübernahme bzw. mit dem Versuch, im Irak einen Regierungswechsel dabei zu führen, dass damit erst der IS gestärkt wurde. Und der IS ist ein Groß, der größte Rivale auch der Iraner. Und der IS ist eine Terrororganisation, die in Deutschland hauptsächlich für die Handschläge verantwortlich ist.
Aber wenn Sie sagen, dass diese Angriffe auf das islamistische Regime im Iran nicht in Deutschland Interesse sind, dann übersehen Sie ja, dass der Iran eben auch islamistische Netzwerke in Deutschland beispielsweise unterstützt.
Das heißt, in der Argumentation, man macht gerade Bombardements im Iran, um den Islamismus hier zu bekämpfen?
Ja, funktioniert bestimmt. Vor allem, wenn Chrupalla schon darauf verweist, dass ja dann wieder Flüchtlinge kommen, wo ja gleich alle Alarmglocken angehen, beteiligten.
Ja, zum Beispiel die Moschee gesehen in Berlin, in denen dann getrauert worden ist über den Tod von Khamenei. Wir hatten das Islamische Zentrum in Hamburg, das genau diese iranische, islamistische Ideologie eben propagiert hat.
Ja, das muss man deswegen meinen. Genau das muss man in Deutschland unterbinden. Das ist aber nicht zu trennen. Aber das schafft man noch nicht mit Bombardements im Iran.
Es scheint auf jeden Fall nicht in Deutschland sicherer zu werden, was den Terrorismus anbelangt. Wenn dieser Krieg da andauert, den Eindruck bekommt man ja nicht. Wenn man das jetzt ja auch hier von Schittler eigentlich hört, also er widerspricht sich ja selbst. Wir hören mal was zur Rolle von Deutschland.
Wie verhindern wir das oder wie ändern wir das? Vor allen Dingen wir Deutschen. Das ist die große Frage.
Deutschland war sehr stark daran beteiligt, dass es jetzt zu dieser Option kommen musste. Deutschland hat ja sehr, sehr lange mit dem Iran sehr, sehr stark zusammengearbeitet. Deutschland war eines der wichtigsten Handelspartner des Iran. Das heißt, deutsche Unternehmen haben Milliardengeschäfte mit dem Iran gemacht, auch mit Unterstützung der deutschen Regierungen. Das heißt, Deutschland hat sich ja geweigert, auch nicht militärische Optionen auszuschöpfen.
Das heißt, Deutschland ist jetzt eigentlich verantwortlich dafür, dass Netanyahu und Trump angreifen müssen.
Ja, also das stimmt ja.
Ja.
Wir wissen ja, wie...
Das ist ja unsinnig....
die über Angst hatten. Also Lieferketten-Gesetz, alles, ach nee, das ist ganz blöd, muss wieder weg, ne? Aber Iran-Sanktionen, ah, können wir noch mal nachgucken, ob wir nicht wirklich irgendwo noch, doch noch in der Lieferkette jemanden haben, der irgendwas mit dem Iran zu tun hat, weil dann haben wir gar kein Amerika-Geschäft mehr. Dann hat man lieber auf Nummer sicher gespielt.
Ja.
Also eigentlich gab es gar keine. Es gab diese Bemühungen, so ein Finanzierungssystem über Bande und so weiter, weil das ist ja alles nichts geworden.
Vor allem zu glauben, dass das, hätte man das nicht noch das ein oder andere versucht, dann wäre was denn passiert? Dann wäre jetzt eigentlich die Iraner liberale Demokratie geworden oder dann hätten die freiwillig gesagt, nukleare Ziele verfolgen wir nicht mehr oder was auch immer. Also das ist und ich hier wieder die Situation, die Leute sitzen vom Fernsehen, hören sich das an und denken, hm komisch, das klingt aber mir nicht sehr plausibel. Da ist der Chrupalla doch mein Mann. Das ist die Situation, in der wir uns da vorfinden.
Man hätte ja viel mehr machen können. Man hätte das iranische Regime sanktionieren können. Man hätte die Botschaften rauswerfen können. Die Terrorzentralen sind in Deutschland.
Ja, also wenn man jetzt Botschaften noch rausgeworfen hätte und noch ein bisschen mehr sanktioniert, dann hätte sich ja genau gar nichts daran erinnert. Vor allem wird hier die ganze Zeit so getan. Als ginge es Trump darum, das Volk zu befreien. Also das finde ich sowieso, dass wir da doch von Trump alles zu gehört haben. Also das finde ich ja, man könnte ja höchstens sagen, möglicherweise sorgt das für so einen Chaos, dass dann so etwas möglich ist. Also das kann man natürlich nie ausschließen. Aber dann wird das, sieht sicherlich nicht das, was Trumps Intention gewesen ist. Und nach der Intention muss man ja wohl fragen. Und nicht jetzt danach, was könnten noch weitere Side-Effects sein, die sehr unwahrscheinlich sind. Chrupalla fragt jetzt mal, ob diese Sanktionspolitik nicht eher kontraproduktiv war. Also ob man nicht einfach da eine Zuspitzung auch damit erzeugt hat. Auch das ist ja eine berechtigte Frage.
Iran angewandt hat, auch in übrigen anderen islamischen Staaten, dass man genau das Gegenteil passiert, dass man da sogar noch eine Solidarisierung mit dem Regime erzeugt. Weil man genau sieht, der böse Westen greift hier ein. Der böse Westen will uns unterdrücken. Wir werden ausgehungert, wie es im Irak zum Beispiel passiert ist.
Sprechen Sie doch mal mit Exili-Iranern und Orten.
Ich spreche mit Iranern, ich kenne Iraner. Ich kenne auch Exili-Iraner. Und ich höre unterschiedliche Stimmen. Die einen, die sagen, das müssen wir selber als Volk mitnehmen, und es gibt auch einige, die sagen, wir begrüßen die Bomber heute morgens. Das will ich überhaupt nicht leugnen, keines der Weise.
Also die stehen sich doch gerade in jeder Stadt direkt gegenüber, hier in Frankfurt auch.
Ja.
Riesige Polizeikette dazwischen und dann, ja.
Was ja logisch ist, dass es da eine Pluralität gibt in den Auffassungen. Weshalb man dann auch nicht sagen muss, ja, fragen Sie mal Exili-Iraner. Dann muss man gleich fragen, ja, welche. So. Und das ist diese Diskussion, die so extrem falsch läuft. Und wie gesagt, wir haben es als direkten Effekt. Das ist jetzt nicht einfach so, ich interessiere mich mal ein bisschen für Geopolitik und beziehe irgendeine Seite, sondern die Seite, die die meisten Menschen beziehen werden, ist, weil es gar keine andere Wahl für sie gibt, die ökonomische Seite. Und Sie sehen, da ist ein Krieg. Offenbar tut Deutschland nicht etwas für mein Portemonnaie, sondern wir sehen dann wieder ein Regierungsversagen. Und das wird Kräfte mobilisieren. Interessanterweise kommt ja auch so, sagen wir von der linkeren Seite, also von Grünen oder der Linkspartei, in diese Richtung auch nicht jetzt ein großes Angebot, sodass da jetzt die AfD wunderbar ein Feld hat, das sie bespielen kann. Und das hat Chrupalla erkannt, wie sehr er sich jetzt für dies oder das interessiert. Also ob er jetzt weniger Transatlantiker ist, als noch gestern oder morgen, das spielt ja da keine Rolle. Er hat einen politischen Instinkt, wie man ja ganz klar hier sehen kann. Und diese Dimension, ich meine, wenn man jetzt gerade den Economic Challenges Podcast vom Handelsblatt mit Rürup und Hüter, dann malen die ja wirklich ein finsteres Bild aus, was das für die Wirtschaft bedeutet. Denn wir sind ja weiterhin exportorientiert, haben eine sehr energielastige Industrie. Wenn dort jetzt die Preise hochgehen, ist auch nicht mehr damit zu helfen, wir machen ein bisschen über Gewinnsteuer und Deckeln irgendwas oder so. Sondern wenn es wirklich diese große reale Knappheit gibt und das über dieses gerade Spekulieren damit hinausgeht und die Knappheit wirklich eine reale wird, dann bedeutet das ja, dass die Rezession sich verlängert oder verschärft. Also dieser kleine Konjunkturfrühling, die man da mal kurz angekündigt hatte, der ist ja fast schon wieder abgeräumt. Die Inflation ist gestiegen, noch hat die EZB offenbar aus, weiß ich nicht, welchen Erwägungen davor zurückgeschreckt, die Zinsen zu erhöhen. Aber wir hören ja schon die Stimmen, dass es in diese Richtung gehen wird. Und das ist einfach ein Fiasco für die europäische Wirtschaft und für die Deutsche insbesondere. Und da wir eine Politik haben, die weiter an Austeritätstreue ist und noch jetzt sagt, ne, wir müssen eigentlich zu den alten Modellen zurück und Verbrenner und sonst was. Und dann höchstens noch versprechen, in 15 Jahren gibt es neue Atomkraftwerke. Dann sehen wir einfach, da ist nichts im Angebot.
Özdemir wurde am letzten möglichen Tag noch in dieses Amt gewählt. Also noch ist er ja nicht im Amt, aber in die Möglichkeit gewählt. Wenn das jetzt erst zur Rheinland-Pfalz-Rei stattfinde, wäre es schon das Reha-Augen-Video egal gewesen.
Wahrscheinlich. Lanz will jetzt noch mal genau wissen, wo steht denn die AfD?
Markus Frohnmaier, der Spitzenkandidat aus Baden-Württemberg, ist ja kurz vor dieser Landtagswahl, also wirklich kurz davor, war auf der entscheidenden Abschlussveranstaltung, Chrupalla lächelt schon ein bisschen maliziös, nicht dabei, nicht dabei sein eigener Wahlkampf. Und ihm ist wichtiger, nach Amerika zu fliegen, um Republikaner zu treffen.
Früher war übrigens Frohnmaier eher der große Russland-Freund.
Über den es immer hieß.
Man sieht ja mittlerweile auch, dass sich das gar nicht mehr unbedingt wieder schrickt.
Es gibt ja ganz kurz, Entschuldigung, weil Sie das kurz anschauen, es ist wichtig, dass die Leute das verstehen. Es gibt doch dieses geleakte Ding aus dem Kreml, wo es heißt, Frohnmaier haben wir unter Kontrolle.
Genau, das ist schon viele Jahre alt. Und seitdem hat sich auch einiges getan in der Position von Frohnmaier. Er sagt auch, er hat mit den Leuten nichts mehr zu tun, die damals wirklich auch sehr nah auch an der Seite Russlands waren. Aber interessant ist, dass die Position gar nicht unbedingt widerspricht, pro Trump und pro Russland zu sein, wenn man sieht, wie Trump zum Beispiel über die Ukraine spricht und sich mit dem Ukrainekrieg verhält.
Auch das kriege ich wieder nicht richtig auseinander. Ja, man kann jetzt sagen, genau das sind diese starken Männern, die jetzt gerade beliebt sind bei Rechten. Bis dahin habe ich es verstanden. Zugleich hat aber jetzt Herr Frederik Schindler ausführlich darauf hingewiesen, dass Trump und Netanyahu dabei sind, das iranische Volk zu befreien. Da soll man sich jetzt nicht als Deutschland den Weg stellen. Wie passt denn das jetzt wiederum zusammen, wenn jetzt Chrupalla aber sagt, nee, genau, das mache ich nicht mit?
Umso besser es nicht zusammenpasst, also umso mehr es nicht zusammenpasst, umso besser für Chrupalla. Ich erinnere daran, es gab diese Zeit als Merkel gegen Seehofer, die große Kontroverse war in der Flüchtlingskrise, wo völlig klar war, für den Koalitionspartner ist hier kein Raum. Wenn es politische Entscheidungen zu treffen gibt, dann zwischen den beiden. Das ist ein bisschen, wie ich schon mal auf Vötor gemacht habe. Der Gegenentwurf zu unserem Text findet bitte bei uns in der Zeitung statt und wird nicht in der Zeit gedruckt. Und so ist das auch. Und so sehr die AfD darunter litt, dass sie an diesem Rentenstreit Ost-West, also in Thüringen möchte man quasi eine Staatsrente und in Baden-Württemberg jeder für sich und so, daran konnte man zerbrechen, weil das betrifft ja die Leute. Aber wenn jetzt der eine kommt und sagt, ich bin Anti-Amerikanist, ich habe 85 Prozent der Leute hier in mir, hinter mir und der andere kommt mit, ich wünsche mir eigentlich einen starken Mann, ich schaue mal nicht so genau hin aus welcher Himmelsrichtung und so weiter, dann hat man, weil das ist so virtuelle Politik, hat man einen Diskurs, der die Leute wirklich fesselt. Da werden Brüder und Bonisten rausgeschält, einen Diskurs, eine Seelgewohnheit eingeübt. Wenn die das durchhalten und die Weltlage sieht ja so aus, als ob das dann auch einmal bei der Bundestagswahl trifft und so, dann müssen die anderen mal gucken, wie sie da noch Diskurs verhalten, wenn man immer nur, ich meine, März versucht es ja so ein bisschen jetzt.
Ja, wir kommen gleich noch zu, Markus Lanz hatte offenbar eine andere These. Möglicherweise gibt es jetzt auch in wenigen Tagen da einen Erwachen, denn am Sonntag wird in Rheinland-Pfalz gewählt. Es ist sehr knapp. Es sieht momentan so aus, als würde die CDU es schaffen mit einem Prozent faun. Das bedeutet, nach 100 Jahren etwa wird die SPD abgelöst. Also wir hatten ja König Kurt Beck Ewigkeiten. Dann kam Marlo Dreyer und wurde dann ersetzt durch Schweizer. Der tritt jetzt nun an gegen den CDU-Kandidaten und möglicherweise hält sich März auch gerade aus strategischen Gründen zurück, weil eine Wahl wurde ja schon verhagelt. Nun, Chrupalla.
Er sucht den Schulterschluss, den Kontakt zur Magerbewegung von Trump. Und Sie sagen, diesen Kriegspräsident reden heute auch hier von Kriegsverbrechen.
Diese Stimmen gibt es doch auch in der Magerbewegung. Wenn ich auch den Vizepräsidenten GD. Vence hier nehme, der auch ganz klar sehr ruhig geworden ist die letzten Wochen und Tage.
Aber er nennt den nicht an Kriegspräsidenten natürlich, ne?
Nochmal, ich habe auch nicht gesagt, ich hoffe, er wird keiner. Und das wird er den amerikanischen Wählern überlassen. Ich bin maßlos enttäuscht von Donald Trump. Es war ganz offen, was seine Wahlversprechen angeht und seine Ankündigungen. Er hat ja auch im Wahlkampf Kamala Harris vorgeworfen, sie würde den Dritten Weltkrieg beginnen. Und jetzt stehen wir an der Schwelle dessen, dass wir wahrscheinlich mit Donald Trump den Dritten Weltkrieg begonnen haben. Und das sind schon Wortbrüche, die ich ihm wirklich auch übel nehme und die ihm auch das amerikanische Volk übel nehmen.
Weißt du, wie sich Wens rausgeredet hat aus der Antwort auf die Frage?
Nein.
Also die Frage steht im Raum, ist Trump jetzt ein Kriegspräsident? Und Wens reagiert nicht drauf, sondern lenkt um auf, naja, bisher hatten wir ja dumme Präsidenten und jetzt haben wir ja einen klugen Präsidenten.
Ach so. Ja, das wird es sein.
Und er stand dabei im Oval Office hinter Trump. Also es war wirklich so Peter Thiel lächelt über die Schulter. Es wird ein gönnerhafter Blick auf, das ist ein kluger Präsident. Er handelt im Sinne der Amerikaner.
Ja.
Und dass es auf der Ebene Krieg oder nicht gerade abläuft, das blenden wir jetzt aus.
Und Klugheit ist immer das Erste, was einem einfällt, wenn man Donald Trumps sieht. Wir gehen jetzt nochmal in das Lager, das das Vorfeld für die AfD medial bereitet, nämlich Nios, aber für die AfD, die transatlantisch bleiben will und sehr androppt an die Weltposition, die wir da gerade gehört haben. Eigentlich machen ja Nios, könnte man sagen, so diese Trecksarbeit, die wühlen so richtig, wo dann selbst der Weltjournalist sagt, das ist mir jetzt ein bisschen zu fies, aber da geht Nios ja nochmal richtig rein. Aber man kann durchaus sehen, dass da eine Argumentation geführt wird, die ja sehr parallel läuft mit dem, was sonst bei Springer gesagt wird. Wir hören Alexander Kissler.
Die Argumentationskette positiv an Trump. Man kann nicht sagen, jahrelang schauen wir weg oder sogar mit Steinmeier haben wir sogar gewisse Aktien an der Solidierung dieses Mullerregimes und jetzt, wo es eine Möglichkeit gibt, das zu entfernen, machen wir uns einen schlanken Fuß und sagen, sicher der Seewege, macht ihr das mal. Mit einer solchen Politik lässt man letzten Endes die deutsche Wirtschaft und damit auch die so hochgerübte Wertegemeinschaft impfen, meine ich.
Das heißt, Deutschland soll Trump zur Seite springen? Julian Reichelt? Gilt für deutsche Wirtschaftsinteressen.
Wenn deutsche Wirtschaftsinteressen in den Händen von Islamisten sind, Geiseln von Islamisten, dann sagt der Bundeskanzler ganz ausdrücklich, wir werden nichts tun, um die Freiheit der Seewege zu gewährleisten. Dann verlässt du dich besser nicht auf den Bundeskanzler.
Er redet dann noch fünf Minuten weiter, dass man sich wirklich auf den Bundeskanzler nicht mehr verlassen kann. Wie kann man nur und so weiter. Wir gehen nochmal zu Lanz zurück. Eine Sendung später ist Kiesewetter dort zu Gast. Die zwei letzten Clips jetzt. Jetzt haben wir Friedrich Merz in den letzten Tagen gehört, dass er sagt, er will nicht Trump unterstützen und er hat da auch jetzt Europäer, die das ähnlich sehen. Aber wir haben jetzt auch schon gehört, dass Merz sagte, zumindest nicht während Kampfhandlungen wird da eine Straße abgesichert. Aus der Geschichte der Bundeswehr. Der letzten 30 Jahre wissen wir ja, immer wieder hat man ja Seewege abgesichert gegen Piraterie, gegen Terrorismus. Man lässt sich da sowieso schon eine Tür offen. Und jetzt sagt Merz, das ist nicht unser Krieg. Der Krieg findet aber ja schon statt in dem schon angesprochenen Portemonnaie eines jeden. Also mich kostet zum Beispiel jetzt der Monat 90 Euro mehr durch den Krieg allein durch das Tanken. Also das kann man ganz klar ausrechnen und dann kann man auch genau wissen, wie viele Leute jetzt gerade wie viel Prozent weniger von ihrem Gehalt haben und was das für einen Ausschlag hat. Ja, da brauche ich noch gar nicht auf eine Inflation zu gucken, sondern das ist dann die Benzininflation und die findet im Portemonnaie statt. Und wenn sich das zuspitzt, dann ist ja Deutschland in der Situation, wo man sich fragen muss, wie soll es dann da weitergehen wirtschaftlich, beziehungsweise wenn wirklich noch ein Druck aufgebaut wird von den USA, dass man sagt, so jetzt aber mal richtig zölle und noch andere Repressionen, die kommen könnten. Also diese Souveränität klingt gerade mutig, aber vielleicht entspricht es nicht der Realität. Wir hören jetzt mal Kiesewetter und Lanz.
Herr Kiesewetter, wenn der Spritpreis dann deutlich über zwei Euro ist, hört das dann auf mit der Moral und mit den klaren Bekenntnissen? Sagen wir dann nach, dann greifen wir doch ein, da müssen wir helfen.
Das ist nicht das Thema. Das eigentliche Thema ist Freiheit der Seewege. Und wir erleben jetzt gerade, dass die Straße von Hormuz gesperrt ist. Die Bundesrepublik als Handelsnation hat in ihrer eigenen Sicherheitsstrategie, dass wir uns weltweit einsetzen für die Freiheit der Seewege.
Das stimmt, aber was heißt das denn nun?
Wir hatten mal einen Bundespräsidenten, Horst Köhler, an dem ich gerade wollte Sie gerade fragen, ob Sie sich noch an Horst Köhler erinnern. 2011 war er bei einem Besuch in Afghanistan, sagte, wir müssen uns auch für die Freiheit der Seewege einsetzen.
Das ist um das Horn von Afrika.
Und dann gab es natürlich auch innenpolitischen Druck und dann ist er zurückgetreten.
Darauf bezieht sich jetzt die CDU positiv und sagt, genau, wir machen das ja, wir wollen ja Seewege schützen.
Das war sicherlich nicht der eigentliche Auslöser, aber trotzdem ist klar, wenn wir als Bundesrepublik Deutschland in unsere eigene Sicherheitsstrategie zurecht schreiben, wir setzen uns für weltweite freie Seewege ein und auch Frau Dunst, ihr und unser Lieblingsthema Völkerrecht gehört dazu, dann muss man aber auch helfen, das Völkerrecht durchzusetzen.
Das heißt, wir müssen dann da runter?
Und jetzt kommt der Punkt. Und wir sagen, das ist nicht unser Krieg, aber es ist natürlich mittelbar unser Benzinpreis.
Das ist unser Fungus.
Es ist nicht unser Krieg, aber es ist unser Benzinpreis. Nein, nein, und das wäre ja eine doppelte Moral.
Ja, und woher würden wir das kennen? Aus Deutschland ja wohl nicht, dass es doppelte Moral gibt. Nein.
Also das Klima ist was für die Grünen und das Völkerrecht was für diese Journalistin. Und jetzt geht es darum, die sind ja gar nicht mal die Huttis, die man jetzt ins Stein zertrüstet.
Ja, aber ich will nur sagen, das sind die Konflikte, die jetzt da kommen. Also wenn das weitergeht, glaube ich, wird diese Position nicht aufrechterhalten werden. Ich habe da große Bedenken und dann haben wir einen Bundeswehreinsatz, aber wo ganz anders, wo wir es noch vor ein paar Monaten vermutet haben.
Haltet ihr noch ein bisschen durch um Wolfgangs Lebensthema so ein bisschen durchzudiskutieren? Ich hatte Wolfgang einen Clip geschickt schon vor einigen Wochen. Den gucken wir jetzt mal gemeinsam. Wir machen hier diesen Hinweis. Es gibt ausnahmsweise in diesem diskursdrächtigen Format jetzt mal richtig was zu gucken, weshalb es diesen Teil des Salons jetzt auch im Forum einfach als Video zur Nachschauung gibt. Ich werde die Instagram Videos, aus denen wir das hier schauen, auch verlinken und so. Aber damit man alles in einem rutscht, machen wir es einfach als Video. Also ich habe Wolfgang dieses Video geschickt.
Ich bin wirklich beschäftigt.
Kannst du Sophia heute holen?
Nein, ich habe ein Gespräch.
Ich kann nicht.
Oh verdammt, okay. Ich habe eine Geomagnetik-Sturm-Reportierung.
Das ist ein Phänomenal, erheblich von einem massiven Versuch.
Ich liebe dich.
Ich bin auf meinem Weg.
Ich brauche dich zu schütteln.
Schönen Morgen, Schleifbeauty.
Warum hast du nicht den Präsidenten auf dem Telefon?
Wir haben sie. Ich bin gleich da. Spektakuläre Flucht aus einer großen Stadt, Flugzeuge fallen auf Straßen.
Na, ich.
Michael Bay.
Genau.
Und wie so eine Mischung da raus. Und am Ende geht noch Donald Trump ans Telefon.
Also das sind hier Produktionskosten keine. So ist der Scherz, denn die Legende sagt, jemand hat das seit Nacht zusammengepromptet. Und sieht aber aus. Also klar, ich habe das jetzt natürlich aus einem Porträt Video bei Instagram wieder hochgezogen auf quer und so weiter. Also es ein bisschen verpixelt, aber im Grunde ist das, was wir gesehen haben. Und das kann man jetzt einfach so machen. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage. Ich als Michael Bay, ja, mir ist ja egal, was irgendwer wollte, der Regisseur, der Drehbuchautor, die Schauspieler. Ich will einfach nur, dass alles kaputt geht. Und das kriege ich ja hier geliefert.
Ich kann da nicht widersprechen. Das bekommst du geliefert. Meine Ansprüche an Filme sind mitunter andere. Aber ich verstehe, was du meinst. Das heißt, viele Filme, auch wenn sie andere Qualität noch haben, leben ja häufig von solchen spektakulären Szenen. Wir haben es ja kürzlich auch gehört, als Matt Damon, ich glaube, bei Joe Rogan war, dass man dann von Netflix solche Anforderungen gestellt bekommt, lasst es bitte den ersten fünf Minuten richtig doll knallen mit Riesenverfolgungsjagden und Explosionen, damit das Publikum erst mal reingezogen wird. Und früher hätte man das eher vielleicht ruhiger aufgebaut. Und das große spektakuläre Finale kommt zum Schluss. Aber das haben sich die Produktionsbedingungen verändert. Jedenfalls habe ich auch einen Filmanalysen früher schon mehrfach moniert, dass man bei vielen der Actionfilme gar nicht mehr weiß, wo oben und unten ist. Und am Ende begegnen sich immer die widersstreitenden Protagonisten irgendwo auf dem Hochhaus und einer wird runtergeschubst. Das heißt, das ist ja sowieso sehr generisch. Und da fragt man sich auch, sollen wir da nochmal irgendwas drehen? Beziehungsweise müssen wir jetzt nochmal alle verraten in der Black Box oder in der Blue oder Green Box? Oder ist es da vielleicht sinnvoller? Wer fragen die KI, ob sie es gerade machen?
Genau, das ist das eine. Produktionskosten gering, sag ich mal.
Und wir wissen ja, die Alisens kaufen nach und nach Hollywood komplett auf und haben ja genau das schon angekündigt, dass man dann mal schauen kann, was die KI da an Prozessoptimierung hinlegen kann.
Genau. Das Zweite ist, man kann ja jetzt auf ZU-UF, also auf Brandbasis, die Filmgeschichte, die man schon kennt, neu schreiben, was natürlich in einer Welt, in der wir alle an Main-Character-Syndrom leiten. Also wir haben alle eine Kamera in der Tasche, filmen uns und stellen dann fest, die Anleitung des Typs auf YouTube, der uns gezeigt hat, wie man sinäastische Urlaubsvideos machen, das geht gar nicht auf. Da hilft jetzt die KI. Hier wird jetzt in einem anderen Maße Geschichte neu, also Filmgeschichte neu geschrieben. Es ist natürlich eine Schiffre. Es ist in dem Falle Sidney Sweeney.
Mr. President, it's the Chinese. What happened?
It's called Sea Dance 2.
They've lost control of the AI.
It's recasting every film with Sidney Sweeney.
By morning there won't be a Hollywood left.
Oh my god!
Where are the aircraft carriers?
Alles klar, hör auf.
Operation Fat Milkers ist eine kinetische Töne-Mission.
Ich muss euch nicht erinnern, was hier an Steig ist.
Madame Präsident, alles ist jetzt Sidney Sweeney.
Seedance 3 wird für den Release geplant.
Lieblings-Schauspieler und Lieblingsfilme.
Deinen Lieblings-Schauspieler?
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Aber ich habe Lieblings-Schauspieler und Lieblingsfilme und es matcht nicht.
Ja, das kann passieren.
Aber ich kann es jetzt matchen vielleicht.
Also du willst jetzt den Michael Bay-Film sehen mit wem? Wen würdest du jetzt gerne sehen?
Ich würde gerne den aktuellen Oscar-Preisträger für den besten Film nochmal in meinem Lieblingsfilm sehen, also in The Rock. Ja, das kann ich jetzt für einen Zusammenprompten vielleicht.
Ja, das suggeriert immer so, dass man eigentlich den idealen Film kennt, man hat ihn nur nicht bekommen. Das glaube ich ja überhaupt nicht. Sondern wir wollen schon, also wir haben eine gewisse Pfadabhängigkeit, was die Starz anbelangt, aber wir wollen schon konfrontiert werden mit dem, von dem wir noch nicht wussten, dass wir es wollten. Also ich weiß, ich habe nun wirklich viel gesehen.
Es ist ungefähr hundert Prozent der Leute zustimmend und ich werde auch wieder Sprachnachrichten bekommen, in denen es heißt...
Schreibt Stefan nochmal, dass er wieder die Kunst abschaffen will.
So, nur für mich ist ja Film nicht zwingend Kunst.
Aber jetzt, ich will hier... Gut, aber Kulisse, dann kann ich ja sagen, ich kann natürlich auch die Videokassette kaufen mit dem Kaminfeuer. Dann brauch ich keinen Kamin. Die Leute, die einen Kamin haben, werden sagen, ist mit Kamin dann doch nochmal was anderes. Worum es mir aber jetzt hier geht. Hollywood ist ja jetzt nicht seit gestern auf die Idee gekommen, was mit Computer zu machen. Das heißt, die Special Effects, die in den letzten 25 Jahren vor allem entstanden sind und was dann nochmal in den letzten acht Jahren passierte, ist einfach so wahnsinnig an technischem Fortschritt. Verglichen einfach mal mit so Filme aus den Nuller Jahren, also wo man auch sieht, okay, da war man noch nicht so weit, da hatte das noch nicht so ganz funktioniert. Dann kann man erst mal sagen, ja, das ist ja eine Computerleistung, die jetzt noch sehr stark händisch auch da ist, dass da sehr, sehr viele Leute programmieren müssen, weshalb ja auch Hollywood dazu übergegangen ist, sehr viel outzusourcen. Also da gibt es ja auch Click-Working bei den Hollywood-Filmen. Und jetzt solche Explosionen, solche spektakulären Bilder mit der KI zu erzeugen, ist ja fast, möchte ich behaupten, ein logischer Schritt.
Aber wir sehen jetzt hier in den kurzen Szenen und die uns jetzt nur zuhören, sollten wirklich mal auf den einen oder anderen Link klicken, sich das ansehen. Sobald dann nur ein Halbsatz gespielt werden muss, funktioniert es ja nicht.
Ja, noch nicht. Mal sehen. Das will ich jetzt gar nicht aufmachen. Wir machen nur Collage-mäßig.
Ja, ja, ich will das nur sagen. Ich will sagen, dass das eine, glaube ich, funktioniert sehr gut. Hier, wo das Je ne sais quoi dazu kommt, da wird es anders.
Nächstes Beispiel ist, wir gehen ja gerne in die Oper, weil da gesungen wird und das Singen, unabhängig davon, ob man sich's erklären kann oder nicht, einfach eine Autospacerfahrung ist. Was wäre jetzt, wenn man den Lieblingsfilm schon hat, aber gerne möchte, dass da mehr gesungen wird?
Du bist auf diesem Kanzler, aber wir haben dir nicht den Rang des Master erzielt.
Wir können hier ein bisschen springen. Ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wie es weitergeht. Es ist natürlich ein richtiger Battle. Wir springen hier zum...
Ich habe ein Grün in der Pipe.
Ich will das ein bisschen korrigieren. Was wir ja hier sehen ist, also was ich eben gesagt hab, will ich korrigieren. Das was wir hier sehen ist ja schon, dass es ziemlich ausgefeilt ist in diesem Bereich. Das heißt auch miemisch passiert schon relativ viel. Und wenn man jetzt bedenkt, dass die Karriere von Train the Rock Johnson darauf fußt, dass er diese eine Augenbraue anheben kann, würde ich sagen, ist die KI dem weit überlegen. Und da kommen wir eigentlich in diesen Rahmen. Du hast eben gesagt, KI als Assistent, als Tool. Die Filmproduktion der Zukunft wird natürlich, also bei diesen Blockbuster-Filmen, immer mehr in diese Richtung gehen, dass man eine Lizenzierung vornimmt der einzelnen Stars. Die spielen dann auch Teile, aber gerade wo man die dann zum Beispiel zusammen in eine Szene bringen muss und so, wäre das vielleicht besser. Wir prompten da gerade was oder wir haben schon mal mehrere Varianten, die wir dann mit dem Prompt produzieren können. Vielleicht auch der Film noch mal als eine, also wir haben ja eh schon so regionenspezifische Dinge, dass man weiß, wenn man in dem Markt sein will, dann darf da nicht geraucht werden und dies nicht und das nicht. Und da wäre natürlich das ein Leichtes, so was mit KI weiterzuführen. Was sich gehört hat, ich hatte ja einen Abend mit Axel Millberg, Kommissar Borowsky war der, ich habe so einen Abend mit ihm gemacht, zum Thema Umberto Eco bei The Dit Cologne und da erzählte er mir, dass das schon so, jetzt sei man, bekommt einen Vertrag vorgelegt und da steht dann drin, hiermit ist man auch einverstanden, dass wenn man synchronisiert wird, dass dann die Stimme genommen wird und dann mit der KI die Synchronisation hergestellt wird und dann sagt, naja und wenn man sich weigert, das zu unterschreiben, das kann man natürlich machen, oder das einzuschränken, vor welchem Gericht der Welt würde man das eigentlich einklagen können? Also da sind die Schauspieler natürlich auch aufgeschmissen. Er hat sich das dann mal angeguckt, auch mit einer albanischen Fassung, wo dann seine Stimme zu hören ist und er sagt, das wird den Synchronisationsmarkt schon sehr leerfähigen. Zumindest für das, was man so für den alltäglichen Gebrauch benötigt.
Jetzt kommt ein Clip über den ganz expliziten Microfile.
Aber ich wollte nur das noch gerade sagen. Das klingt jetzt so, als könne man das damit ersetzen. Aber es ist eben nicht eine Ersetzung. Jetzt ist Synchronisation immer schon ein Behelfsmittel. Da sind wir uns alle einig. Das ist eigentlich toll, wenn man würde alle Schauspieler nur im Original hören und könnte sie im Original auch verstehen. Also müsste nicht Untertitel lesen. Aber was ich dann erlebe, wenn ich da mit jemandem wie Axel Millberg sitze, der kann ja selbst aus den leblosesten Texten, denen man ihm hinlegt, die lebendig machen, dass man fasziniert ist, was eigentlich mit einer Stimme geht. Ich sitze daneben und denke, das gibt es gar nicht, man vertraut sich gar nicht danach selbst zu reden, weil man nur so fisselig sich vorkommt. Und das ist natürlich etwas, was dann nicht mehr da ist, sondern das ist dann das Generische plötzlich, wo der große Schauspieler sein eigenes reinlegen kann. Und dass das verlustig geht durch die KI, das ist meine große Sorge.
Ja, oder? Dieser Raum, so wieder neuit, überhaupt das mal definiert. Man geht ins Kino, weil man weiß, Nolan hat alles auf seinem IMAX gedreht. Der nächste Clip hier hat ganz explizite Michael Bay-Bezüge, denn es geht um Transformers. Aber es wird etwas gezeigt, was sich auch Michael Bay, obwohl er es sich offenbar gewünscht hat, nicht wirklich verwirklichen konnte. Nämlich, dass sich der Transformer gerade transformiert und der Mensch in der Szene bleibt. Statt Tür auf, Mensch raus, Transformer, Mensch wieder im Gespräch, wie auch immer. Und es sieht sehr beeindruckend aus. Hier darf man sich natürlich keine Frage mehr stellen, die man ja schon lange nicht mehr stellt. Warum leuchtet das Licht blau? Es ist halt einfach passieren als Sachen. Man klettert einfach mal aus dem fliegenden Flugzeug raus. So, jetzt kommt, was ich eben schon ansprach. Wir alle haben Main Character für Leute, die sich aus, also man muss ja nicht mehr so viel auskennen, aber die Zeit und Lust dafür haben. Das, was wir jetzt gleich sehen, könnte man sich auch mit Wolfgang vorstellen. Wir fangen mal an. Es ist ein sehr langer Clip. Wir springen deswegen. Wir schauen mal in den Anfang rein.
I'm so screwed.
Also typisches Szenario, jemand flüchtet. Und jetzt suchen wir mal hier die Szenerie. Ich glaube, sie ist so ungefähr hier. Ah ja. So, also ein Held taucht auf, befreit sie aus misslicher Lage. Und jetzt sehen wir mal, wer das ist und fragen uns, könnte das nicht auch die Wolfgang M. Schmitt Show sein?
Das war jetzt Jake Paul oder sein Oder.
Sein Bruder taucht dann später auch noch auf. Das sieht man hier. Ganz interessant.
Also warum hast du jetzt bei diesem Typ mit Sixpack da mich als erstes denken müssen, dass das auf eine Rolle sein soll, die mir zuzuhören?
Die Pointe ist ja hier, jemand taucht auf uns. Das ist eine mexikanischen Wrestlermästige. Man weiß nicht, wer das ist.
Und das kann doch ich sagen können.
Klar. Der Enthüllung erlaubt alles. Wir sehen noch mal kurz, wie sein Bruder Jake hier eingeführt wird.
Ich muss nicht ins Fitnessstudio dafür gehen.
Genau, das wird ja hier.
Das ist wie bei Thor. Weißt du, das ist nichts als das Zeitpunkt, als ich Tyson kämpfte.
Wir beschreiben kurz, das ist der gebrochene Kiefer und so weiter hier einfach mit eingebaut.
Ja.
Das ist quasi tagespolitische Verwirklichung in einem. Ja, das ist wirklich verrückt. So, was macht man mit KI? Nicht viel mehr Blödsinn, als den, den man von Hollywood schon kennt. Dieses Metier, was wir hier kurz sehen, ist uns allen bekannt.
Arigato, Trinity.
Wir müssen gar nicht weiter gucken. Das ist genau das, was du anmerktest. Matrix 1, 2, 3 ist durch, Matrix 4 ist durch. Bei Matrix 5 wird der Netflix sagen, machen wir, aber Neo muss blau leuchten und zwischendurch muss es unklar sein, ob er auf die böse Seite gewechselt ist. Mhm. Dass es jetzt mit KI zu machen ist, ist ganz kleines Novum. Kann man auch in die Editorische Notiz schreiben, aber das ist im Grunde. Jetzt kommt eine Art Trailer. Das sind ja kleine Anheizer-Programme, die uns mehr versprechen. Man könnte aus dem, was wir jetzt sehen, also einen ganzen Film stricken. Und ehrlich gesagt, ab jetzt läuft auch ein Countdown. Wann sehen wir diesen Film?
Drei Jahre nach einem String von kranker, unentschlossenen Mördern der lokalen Coeds mit möglichen Fettmilchern. Die Frauen von Delta Delta D werden zur neuen Space Station als Teil des NASA-Projektes Bust.
Schrecklich, der Tittekiller ist gerade weg.
Wir werden 250 Meilen hoch.
Ich meine, wir haben ja jetzt eine große Deepfake-Debatte bekommen durch das, was jetzt Colin Fernandes dem Spiegel erzählt hat und zur Anzeige gebracht hat. Wir werden vielleicht Ende des Monats darauf kommen, mal sehen, wie das weiter verläuft und was man dazu behaupten kann zu diesen Unglaublichkeiten. Aber was wir jetzt sicherlich erleben werden, ist, dass wir so einen Boom an diese Art des Deepfakes bekommen, wo auch einfach klar ist, die Schauspieler werden Knebelverträge unterschreiben müssen. Alles dann mit ihm gemacht wird.
Absolut.
Also, dass das genau solche Erwägungen sind. Wir haben eine Zeit, wo Miley Cyrus gesagt hat, dass sie als Hannah Montana eben nicht zu fraulich wirken sollte. Und so musste dann quasi so sich abbinden, dass das nicht zu fraulich aussieht, damit sie diese Rolle weiterspielen kann. Also sieht man schon, wie das Hollywood-System sozusagen den weiblichen Körper da formt und deformiert, wie es einem da recht ist. Und dass das jetzt quasi über die KI in so eine Richtung gehen kann, dass man sagt, wir produzieren da jetzt mehr Oberweite oder sonst was, ist, glaube ich, etwas, was wir schrecklicherweise dann erleben werden. Weil diese Schauspieler, wenn sie jetzt nicht die absoluten Megastars sind, sich dem gar nicht entziehen können.
Ja, und das ist jetzt quasi Consumer Electronic. Also es ist ganz erstaunlich.
Imagine any idea you could imagine, you could create. Now you can. Introducing Gen 4.5 Image to Video. Take any image, real, generated, iconic, sketched, scribbled, rendered or illustrated and bring it to life in any way you want. Like a horse runs through the gallery. Generate consistent photoreal characters, epic establishing shots, dizzying chases, big budget visual effects, product shots and ads, and even give it hyper specific directions. Like a man in the back of the cab, whip pan to a monkey driving, whip pan back to the man surrounded by pigs, whip pan back to the driver that's now a pig. Yeah, it can do that. Any story you have to tell, movie you want to make, ad you need to ship, or random idea you want to explore, because maybe it will sort of be interesting if you can just see it the way you see it in your head. You can do that. With Gen 4.5 Image to Video. Available now.
Was halt hier auch bedeutet, wenn jetzt einfach nur ein Bild reicht, der Computer muss ja alle, also wirklich jedes Einzelteil des Bildes verstehen, um das zu rekombinieren. Was eben bedeutet, alles was in einem Bild zu sehen ist, ist dem Computer bekannt. Also das ist, wir haben ja jetzt dieses Video von Bernie Sanders, wie er mit Claude über Überwachung spricht und was es für Privacy bedeutet und so. Alles Geschichte. Also wirklich einfach alles vorbei. Das sieht dann zu Hause so aus.
So, Test. Ich teste jetzt hier gerade das neue Motion.
Achtet mal darauf, ich weiß nicht genau ob man es sieht. Man sieht, wenn man nah dran ist, dass sein Mund unten gar nicht mitspricht, sondern nur oben das Original wiegt.
Transfer Tool von Kling und kann mich damit theoretisch in einen Astronauten verwandeln und trotzdem mein Acting übertragen. Was mich aber besonders interessiert ist, ob ich mit Objekten noch interagieren kann oder wenn ich hier zum Beispiel einen nassen Sack aufhebe, kurz das Bild verlasse und dann wiederkomme mit einem nassen Sack. Das ist übrigens die Raya. Die ist bei unserer Pflegestell immer noch und würde sich freuen, wenn es mal Anfragen gäbe, damit sie adoptiert wird. Naja, meldet euch. In der Nähe von Darmstadt wohnen wir und wir haben die Raya hier auf Pflegestell. Und sie freut sich über ihr Fett immer zu Hause. Ich leg sie mal ab. 25 Kilo? Ungefähr.
Also man denkt jetzt hier, okay, da hat jemand sich einen neuen Körper gegeben oder was auch immer. Aber nein, dieses Bild ist einfach generiert. Auch sein unveränderter Kopf ist hier in dieses Bild reingegeneriert. Also für Sachen wie, Herr Colin Fernandes war in irgendwelchen Videotelefonaten und so und alle fragen sich, hey, wie geht denn das? Hat sie das nicht mitbekommen? Ne, muss sie ja nicht. Also das sind wirklich krasse Sachen. Weshalb wir zum Finale dieses kleine Video gucken, das ist natürlich sehr provozierend. Man muss jetzt nicht mehr dazu sagen, das ist alles KI. Aber es ist sehr amüsant. Das geht eine Minute 15.
Everything you're looking at here, it's all built. None of this street existed three months ago. It took four years and 17 million dollars to build the whole city. We built the entire city because we weren't sure what the drone would capture from above.
The bridge alone took a year, 500 tons of steel and three different paint formulations to get the frost right.
This whole film hinges on one leaf.
We knew it had to be the greatest leaf anyone had ever seen.
We auditioned, I think, 400 leaves, maybe more.
I lost count after the Uruguay batch.
We flew to Brazil, to Germany, Iceland, just chasing the perfect vein structure.
We tried a dozen different leaves on the floor. None of them really carried the weight we wanted. Leaves wrinkle under lights, they curl, they get nervous, I swear.
I wasn't happy with how the leaf looked, I just didn't feel it.
We're still on 8Camp.
So instead of the leaf, we used a real actor playing the leaf.
Then we replaced the actor with CGI.
Profoundly embarrassing, obviously. One spends weeks perfecting the texture, the stillness, only to be digitally replaced.
We would never use AI in our filmmaking process. It's important to spend $17 billion on a bridge. But it's important.
AI can't replicate this experience.
It can't feel the cold.
It can't understand the struggle. If it's not real snow, it's not really filming.
No one can play the leaf like I do.
Das heißt, dass man kann auch eigentlich das Making-of total faken. Man macht einen KI-Film und dann macht man noch mal ein Making-of-Fake, in dem man sagt, wir haben, glaube ich, viele Kulissen gebaut und seht her, was wir alles gemacht haben. Ja, es ist eine gute Pointe, aber gestatte mir das. Wir sagen das jetzt auch, gestatte mir, dass ich da einhacke. Was diesen Bildern wird fehlen ist eine wirkliche Präsenz. Das haben sie nicht. Und das kann man jetzt auch schon bei diesen Netflix-Produktionen, die ja auch schon auf KI und so was setzen, kann man das auch einfach schon nachvollziehen, dass das nicht da ist. Ich habe ihn schon mal hier erwähnt, Henning von Gierke, ein wichtiger Künstler, der mit Werner Herzog zusammengearbeitet hat, der sagte, wenn er Ausstattung gemacht hat, dann musste in den Schubladen etwas liegen, auch wenn die Schubladen geschlossen blieben. Um zu sagen, nur dann funktioniert es wirklich, dass das Räumliche spürbar wird. Und wenn ich mir einen Film ansehe wie Poor Things, wo auch sehr viel gebaut wurde, dann spürt man das in einer anderen Weise. Und deswegen gehen wir im Übrigen ja auch in die Oper, weil wir da diese Kulisse sehen wollen. Man könnte auch einfach sagen, die stehen vorne und dann lassen wir hinten was projizieren und das war's. Würde uns nicht genügen. Das heißt, ich glaube, dass das für viele Bereiche des Films, also wo das wirklich so um schnelle Ware geht, also das, was bei Netflix schon sehr dominant ist, aber auch woanders natürlich auch im Kino, dass das sich da weiter durchsetzen wird und das ist schade, weil es natürlich auch das Sehen zerstört. Aber in den Bereichen, wo es um mehr geht, also einfach nur was generisch herzustellen, wird es sich nicht durchsetzen. Die Frage ist nur, wie viele Bereiche bleiben, in denen noch das andere dann gemacht werden kann und wie viele euch Ideen wird sich Hollywood noch gönnen?
Also du hast recht. Und es gibt ja auch diese eine große Konstante, nämlich dein Unmut darüber, dass es nur sehr wenige Leute so sehen wie du.
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, dass es sehr viele Leute so sehen eigentlich.
Ich habe gesehen, wie es in Avatar ging. Es war wohl ein Milliardenumsatz. Bei denen...
Ja, da ist es egal. Würde ich auch sagen. Das würde ich mir jetzt auch als James Cameron mal gut überlegen, ob man sich jetzt da noch weiter für ausgaben will oder einfach noch so zwei, drei Jahre abwartet und dann den Prompt eingibt. Weil die Story ist ja eh schon Chachipiti 2.1.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen. Ich habe nur eure Zusammenfassung. Das war meine Unterhaltung dazu. Sehr gut. Dann sehen wir uns am Ende des Monats wieder und besprechen dann Iran und die Kleinkriege in deutschen Familien.
Wir schauen, was da kommt. Einen schönen Abend. Vielen Dank.